notre politique migratoire les ministres
reviendront dans un instant sur ces
principes directeurs
comme je l'avais annoncé ce projet de
loi fait l'objet d'une vaste
concertation le ministre de l'Intérieur
la conduit avec l'appui de la secrétaire
d'État à la citoyenneté le ministre du
Travail s'y est également pleinement
engagé
le texte doit consolider les avancées de
la loi asile immigration et adapter
notre droit au défi actuel de la
question migratoire je l'ai dit à
l'Assemblée nationale et je le répète
devant vous nous n'avons qu'une boussole
l'efficacité nous porterons un texte
équilibré aux effets utiles et concrets
il me semblait donc important essentiel
même avant la finalisation du projet de
loi et comme je m'y étais engagé de
venir devant vous pour vous présenter
des faits des orientations et pour en
débattre
alors mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs commençons par les faits
d'abord oui il existe une immigration
légale je le dis car à entendre certains
ont l'oublierait cette immigration
légale ce sont des salariés qualifiés ou
encore les personnes que les Françaises
et les Français ont choisi d'épouser
j'entends souvent dire que le nombre de
titres délivrés à progresser c'est juste
la tendance ne date pas d'hier et elle
s'est vérifiée sous des majorités de
gauche comme de droite ainsi en 15 ans
le nombre de titres de séjour délivrés
est passé de façon progressive de 172000
en 2016 à 271 000 en 2021
mais ne nous trompons pas sur les causes
de cette augmentation
contrairement aux caricatures
l'immigration familiale a baissé sur
cette période s'il y a eu une
augmentation c'est pour trois raisons
d'abord parce que notre enseignement
supérieur est attractif et que depuis
2017 le nombre d'étudiants que nous
accueillons à doubler c'est une bonne
nouvelle ces étudiants apprennent à
parler français à connaître notre pays
et le font rayonner dans le monde
deuxième raison de cette hausse le
nombre de salariés qualifiés et de
chercheurs que nous que nous accueillons
à augmenter en 15 ans et cela a
bénéficié à notre économie à nous
entreprises à notre innovation enfin
dernière raison de la hausse
l'augmentation modérée du nombre de
bénéficiaires de l'asile ce sont 30000
personnes menacées dans leur pays que
nous accueillons chaque année
c'est l'honneur de la France de leur
donner leur place c'est l'honneur de
notre pays d'avoir accueilli 3000
ressortissants afghan juste après la
chute de Kaboul l'an dernier c'est
l'honneur de la France d'avoir accueilli
108000 Ukrainiens depuis le 24 février
dernier sous le statut de la protection
temporaire au nom du gouvernement je
tiens à remercier lofpra les élus locaux
les associations et les employeurs qui
les accompagnent au quotidien
bien sûr nous devons donner à toutes les
personnes arrivées légalement les moyens
d'une intégration digne et complète
certaines difficultés existent encore
notamment en termes d'insertion
professionnelle j'y reviendrai voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
quels sont les faits concernant
l'immigration légale
mais le principal enjeu ça n'est pas
tant la situation de ce à qui nous avons
délivré un titre que celle des personnes
qui se maintiennent sur notre territoire
sans y avoir droit ces personnes ne sont
pas éligibles à l'asile il aura souvent
été explicitement refusé pourtant le
flux de demande augmente nettement ces
dernières années et celles et ceux à qui
nous n'accordons pas la protection reste
encore trop fréquemment sur notre
territoire
souvent victime de passeurs qui leur
promettent l'Eldorado et mettent en
danger leur vie la plupart d'entre eux
vivent dans la grande précarité sans
disposer du droit à travailler et
parfois sombre dans la délinquance
face à ce défi les amateurs de solutions
toutes faites sont nombreux on trouve
les partisans du yakafaucon qui
voudraient renvoyer d'un coup d'un seul
l'intégralité d'entre eux alors oui je
souhaite que le droit et nous frontières
soient respectés oui je souhaite des
éloignements rapides et efficaces des
personnes en situation irrégulière mais
non on ne peut pas prétendre que les
choses soient simples comme si nous
pouvions nous affranchir de
l'indispensable coopération des pays
d'origine et des règles de l'État de
droit de l'autre côté certains appellent
à des opérations de régularisation
massive je le dis aussi clairement il
n'en est pas question nous ne créerons
pas de telles précédents qui ne
régleraient pas les difficultés des
personnes concernées qui donneraient des
arguments au pasteur et qui ne seraient
ni acceptées ni acceptable par les
Français
pour notre part nous voulons prendre le
sujet à bras le corps et proposer des
solutions utiles et efficaces je crois
que nous pouvons nous retrouver sur une
préoccupation commune évitez que des
étrangers restent durablement dans une
situation indéterminée qui ne serait ni
le droit au séjour ni l'éloignement
aussi nous voulons clarifier beaucoup
plus vite la situation des étrangers
arrivés sur notre sol d'une part nous
voulons accélérer les procédures
d'examen des demandes d'asile et du
droit au séjour pour lutter contre les
pratiques dilatoires et d'autre part une
fois la situation clarifiée nous
souhaitons éloigner plus rapidement ce
qui doivent l'être quant aux personnes
qui ont vocation à rester nous voulons
engager plutôt les actions pour réussir
leur intégration d'abord par la langue
et l'emploi
ces principes sont les grands axes de
travail du gouvernement ce sont des
objectifs qui je le crois peuvent
rassembler largement en particulier au
Sénat car je sais pouvoir trouver sur
ces bancs des partenaires pour pour
construire ce texte ensemble les
constats que vous avez formulés dans
votre rapport d'information et qui
faisait l'objet d'un large consensus
parmi les groupes au Sénat monsieur le
Président buffet nous les partageons le
projet de loi que présentera le
gouvernement reprendra ou s'inspirera de
bon nombre de vos propositions pour
celles qui relèvent du domaine
législatif nous en mettrons d'autres en
œuvre je pense à celles qui concerne
l'indispensable amélioration de
l'accueil en préfecture et les modalités
de recueil et de traitement des demandes
de titres de séjour j'y reviendrai et le
ministre de l'Intérieur également
je retiens cette volonté de travail
commun cette volonté de bâtir des
solutions au-delà des clivages et des
postures et c'est pourquoi comme pour la
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur je vous
confirme que nous examinerons le futur
projet de loi d'abord au Sénat je
souhaite ainsi que nous puissions bâtir
une majorité solide sur ce texte on nous
appuyant notamment sur l'important
travail déjà réalisé par les sénateurs
sur ces sujets migratoires
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
comme l'a dit le président de la
République nous devons déployer une
action complète cohérente et efficace en
amont des flux migratoires et après
l'arrivée sur notre territoire nous
voulons d'abord prévenir les débaris
réguliers en contribuant grâce à notre
aide publique au développement à traiter
les causes profondes des migrations que
sont la pauvreté et de plus en plus les
effets du dérèglement climatique ensuite
nous devons mieux protéger nos
frontières pour y parvenir notre premier
levier d'action est européen
pendant la présidence française du
Conseil de l'Union européenne nous
sommes parvenus à plusieurs avancées
autour du pacte sur la migration et
l'asile en particulier pour rendre plus
efficace les contrôles à l'arrivée en
Europe et pour renforcer le mécanisme de
solidarité pour les états de première
entrée dans le respect du droit maritime
nous devons maintenant continuer nous
poussons pour un renforcement des moyens
de Frontex et pour une réforme de
l'espace Schengen nous voulons également
consolider le système d'asile européen
et c'est aussi à l'échelle européenne
que nous lutterons plus efficacement
contre les réseaux de passeurs le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
le ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères Catherine Colonna et la
secrétaire d'État en charge de l'Europe
Laurence Boon sont pleinement mobilisés
en ce sens
le deuxième moyen d'action c'est au
niveau national en renforçant le
contrôle à nos frontières et en
accélérant les procédures en novembre
2020 le président de la République a
annoncé le doublement des effectifs à
nos frontières les résultats sont là 10
000 refus par mois ont été prononcés en
2021 contre 3000 début 2020 avant le
covid ensuite nous devons accélérer les
procédures d'examens des demandes
d'asile dans ce domaine des progrès ont
été réalisés dans le précédent
quinquennat les délais de l'OFPRA ont
considérablement diminué mais ceux des
procédures contentieux sont encore trop
longs au total le délai moyen de
traitement d'une demande d'asile est
encore de l'ordre d'un an nous devons
donc accélérer et viser un délai global
de 6 mois pour l'ensemble de la
procédure nous voulons notamment
réformer le contentieux des étrangers
pour le réduire et le simplifier nous
voulons passer de 12 procédures
contentieuses à 4 suivant en cela les
recommandations du Conseil et du rapport
d'information du président buffet le
ministre de l'Intérieur il reviendra et
travaillent également avec le ministre
de la Justice
Eric Dupond-Moretti à une réforme de la
Cour nationale du droit d'asile enfin
nous voulons éloigner plus
systématiquement et plus efficacement
les personnes déboutées du droit d'Asie
nous devons augmenter nos capacités en
centre de rétention administrative et
nous continuerons à agir dans nos
relations bilatérales avec les pays qui
refusent de réadmettre leur propre
ressortissants par ailleurs nous devons
être intraitables avec les étrangers
délinquants même en situation régulière
s'engager dans la délinquance c'est se
placer en dehors de notre communauté
nationale c'est porter une atteinte
grave à notre pacte social et à nos
compatriotes c'est également nuire à
tous les étrangers qui vivent en France
et qui construisent paisiblement des
parcours d'intégration réussie dont on
ne parle pas
grâce à l'action déterminée du ministre
de l'Intérieur et des préfets plus de
3000 lettres étrangers hauteur de
troubles à l'ordre public ont été
éloignés en 2021 et 2022 enfin sous le
contrôle du juge et dans le respect de
nos engagements conventionnels des
mesures d'expulsion doivent désormais
pouvoir être prises contre les étrangers
quel que soit leur situation qui
commettent des infractions graves
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
le disais nous portons une vision
équilibrée si nous voulons que ceux qui
ne doivent pas rester part c'est aussi
pour pouvoir mieux intégrer ce que nous
accueillons cela passe d'abord par une
refonte en profondeur de l’accueil en
préfecture pour les démarches de
renouvellement des titres des étrangers
en situation régulière nous devons
éviter les pertes de droit notamment
d’emploi que peuvent connaître certaines
personnes fautes d'accès au guichet pour
les demandeurs d'asile nous devons aussi
continuer à renforcer nos capacités
d'hébergement en cinq ans nous les avons
déjà augmenté de plus de 36000 places
enfin le pivot de notre politique
d'intégration c'est le travail dans un
pays dont le taux de chômage est de 7,3%
nous devons d'abord chercher à pouvoir
les pour pouvoir les postes vacants en
proposant ses emplois à nos
ressortissants et aux personnes en
situation régulière le taux d'emploi des
immigrés en France et 9 points plus
faibles que celui de l'ensemble de la
population nous devons travailler à
réduire cet écart ensuite si les
employeurs ne sont pas parvenus à
trouver la main d'oeuvre dont ils ont
besoin ils peuvent la faire venir de
manière légale un employeur peut
toujours solliciter une autorisation de
travail si démontre qu'il n'a pas pu
pourvoir le poste en déposant une offre
auprès de Pôle Emploi pour certains
métiers particulièrement en tension
l'employeur est même dispensé de cette
justification nous avons simplifié ces
dispositifs en 2019 pour mieux répondre
aux besoins enfin la question de la
régularisation
se poser pour des personnes en situation
irrégulière présente sur notre sol
depuis des années et qui travaille
depuis longtemps ce sujet mérite mieux
que des caricatures il ne s'agit en
aucun cas d'une régularisation massive
ni de laisser penser que la
régularisation serait la réponse aux
tensions sur le marché du travail il
s'agit de régulariser certaines
personnes qu'il contribuent depuis
longtemps à la richesse nationale mais
qui subissent parfois des conditions de
travail indignes et restent enfermés
dans un statut précaire le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft il reviendra
plus en détail enfin mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs s'intégrer c'est
parler la langue de la République alors
que nous proposons des cours de langue
dès l'arrivée sur le territoire nous
souhaitons qu'un niveau minimal de
Français soit désormais imposé pour
obtenir des prix des titres de séjour de
plus d'un an
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
tracé devant vous les grands principes
de notre action une action fondée sur la
volonté d'équilibre et la recherche
d'efficacité d'abord agir sur les causes
profondes de l'immigration en lien avec
les pays d'origine et de transit
assurés ensuite le respect de nos
frontières et de notre droit par des
procédures plus rapides et des mesures
d'éloignement mieux appliquées et donnez
enfin à celles et ceux que nous
accueillons les moyens d'intégration
pleine entière et réussie car
l'intégration c'est bien la finalité de
toute politique migratoire autour de ces
principes je suis et je reste convaincu
que nous pouvons construire des réponses
ensemble je sais que le Sénat fidèle à
sa volonté de dialogue et d'actions il
prendra avec nous toute sa part je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais donner la parole
à Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur des Outre-mer monsieur le
ministre
madame la Première ministre
messieurs et les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président
la première ministre de pouvoir dire
quelques mots sur ce débat qui pense sur
la politique migratoire de notre pays au
moment où comme l'annoncer madame la
Première ministre un texte sera déposé
en premier devant la Haute Assemblée un
texte que je porterai avec le ministre
du Travail en lien parfait avec monsieur
le garde des sceaux et qui prévoit
finalement 4 sujets ou quatre thèmes que
je voudrais détailler après la première
ministre le premier celui de la fermeté
le deuxième celui de la simplification
le troisième celui de l'intégration et
le quatrième de celui du travail je
laisserai évidemment ce quatrième thème
évoqué par le ministre du Travail à
lui-même celui de la fermeté parce que
comme l'a dit le président de la
République même dans sa campagne
électorale comme la Haute Assemblée l'a
déjà réclamé comme la Premier ministre
vient de le signifier nous avons
aujourd'hui trop de difficultés à
expulser des personnes qui sont sur
notre sol que nous ne voulons plus et
qui commettent des délictuelle grave ou
des actes criminels ou des personnes qui
sont fichées par nos services de
renseignement non pas par la
jurisprudence des tribunaux non pas par
les engagements constitutionnels ou
conventionnels notre pays mais par les
propres règles que nous nous sommes mis
nous-mêmes dans les années 2000 à
l'occasion sans doute d'un temps qui
n'étaient plus tout à fait celui que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui il s'agit
de mettre dans le texte de la République
la fin des réserves d'ordre public
c'est-à-dire la fin de la fin de la
double peine qui empêche le ministre de
l'Intérieur et les préfets d'expulser du
territoire national toute personne qui a
commis des actes graves condensation
définitive par les tribunaux à plus de 5
ans de prison et qui relève souvent des
crimes des personnes qui s'en prennent
aux femmes ou aux enfants les personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique ou
par exemple les trafics de stupéfiants
aujourd'hui il y a cette réserves
d'ordre public nous proposons de qu'une
qui essaie de l'engagement international
que nous avons porté notamment vis-à-vis
des mineurs il s'agit d'un effet des
mineurs qui commettent des actes
délictuels au criminel lorsqu'ils sont
mineurs puisque là il appartient
évidemment à l'autorité judiciaire de
suivre directement ces personnes mais
nous proposons de lever les autres
restrictions à l'expulsion de nos
concitoyens étrangers qui commettent ces
actes délictuels ou criminels graves et
de pouvoir mettre ainsi dans la loi la
possibilité qu'elle préfère de présenter
à l'exclussion ces personnes évidemment
en respectant l'article 8 de la
Convention de sauvegarde des droits de
l'homme qui prévoit une sorte
d'équilibre entre la vie privée et
familiale et le droit au séjour entre la
Sûreté nationale et la sécurité publique
et la vie privée familiale mais ce que
nous disons nous c'est que ce n'est pas
à la loi de s'autocensurer pour empêcher
ces expulsions 4000 par an pourraient
être prononcés exécuté et comme la
rappeler même la première ministre nous
en sont à 31 depuis deux ans mais c'est
bien au juge de confirmer ou non cette
équilibre entre la vie privée et
familiale et les impératifs de la
sécurité nationale ce que nous
proposerons au Parlement c'est de
supprimer donc ces réserves d'ordre
public et de copier-coller l'article 8
de la Convention européenne de
sauvegarde des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen le deuxième sujet sur lequel je
voudrais ici évoquer c'est celui de
l'augmentation des places de rétention
administrative dans le cas de la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur le gouvernement accepté un
amendement du député
Eric Ciotti d'augmentation jusqu'à 3000
places de centre de rétention
administrative ces centres de rétention
administratifs sont nécessaires pour
pouvoir mieux expulser un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens étrangers qui
commettent des actes de vacances ou qui
sont fichés pour des services de
radicalisation nous connaissons
aujourd'hui une spécificité désormais
dans les centres de rétention
administratif puisque nous y mettons
désormais à 92%, c'est le chiffre de ce
matin des personnes qui ont un casier
judiciaire donc ils sont suivis par les
services de renseignement nous n'y
mettons plus les étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui sont sous le coup certes
d'une qtf mais qui ne présente pas de
danger pour nos concitoyens d'autres
formules sont à prendre c'est à dire
l'assignation à résidence par exemple
depuis que je suis ministre de
l'intérieur j'ai aussi demandé que
progressivement et c'est désormais plus
le cas aujourd'hui à l'exception du
territoire de Mayotte territoire bien
spécifique s'il en est nous pourrons
reparler dans le débat bien évidemment
d'enfants dans un centre de rétention
administratif et à la demande de Madame
la première ministre du président de la
République nous mettrons dans le texte
que nous présentons l'interdiction de
mettre des mineurs dans des centres de
rétention administratifs dans les
prochaines années une fois que ce texte
sera voté l'assignation à résidence sera
évidemment la règle la spécificité du
centre de rétention administratif et
notamment son aspect carcéra mais aussi
les publics que nous y mettons désormais
il y a des publics qui sont dangereux
pour nos concitoyens méritent évidemment
que nous puissions aller vers ce genre
de propositions à la fois d'une
augmentation considérable de place de
Kra nous en avons ne serait-ce que
l'année 2022 augmenter de 450 nombre de
places de craints éligibles et malgré
les contraintes du covid mais évidemment
correspondre à l'augmentation voulue par
le Parlement et peut-être dans quelques
jours promulguer par le Président de la
République de la loopnie tout en
émettant pas des mineurs qui n'ont pas à
connaître ce type de rétention le
deuxième sujet après la fermeté et je
passerai évidemment sur d'autres
dispositifs qui seront contenus dans la
loi il s'agit des un grand acte de
simplification nous aspirons comme la
première ministre directement du rapport
du sénateur buffet qui prévoit en effet
de simplifier de 12 à 4 le nombre de
procédures possibles pour nos
concitoyens qui viendraient tester
évidemment des actes administratifs pris
par des préfets de la République la
longueur de l'attente et des recours
suspensifs empêchent d'avoir une
politique d'immigration dignes de ce nom
digne de ce nom pour notre pays qui
n'arrive pas à faire exécuter
correctement les lois de la République
et lorsque les tribunaux au bout d'un an
d'un an et demi deux ans lui donne
raison les personnes sont souvent plus
expulsables parce que notamment ils ont
fait leur vie privée familiale ce sont
de la République et notamment eu par
exemple des enfants et qui rendent
inexpulsables de notre sol et en même
temps à ceux que nous disons oui
notamment dans le cadre de la demande
d'asile un an et demi deux ans c'est
beaucoup trop long c'est beaucoup trop
long pour pouvoir s'intégrer et pour
pouvoir travailler pour pouvoir vivre
dans le pays qu'il est accueille parmi
les simplifications il y a une
simplification effectivement de la CNDA
que le garde destruction doute reviendra
en partie sur cette question il s'agit
pour nous de la territorialiser pas
garder une seule scène des hame et de
faire des CNDA il s'agit pour nous de
permettre le alors nous entendons la
demande du Conseil d'État et de la CNDA
de garder une instance collégiale pour
des arrêts de principe je crois que le
texte nous présenterons correspondra à
la demande du Conseil d'État mais que
l'immense majorité des décisions
puissent se prendre en jujunique afin de
pouvoir être beaucoup plus efficace et
beaucoup plus rapide il s'agit de mettre
en place sa vision conférence par
exemple et il s'agit évidemment de
pouvoir simplifier le lien entre le
refus ce qui est le cas 70% de la
demande d'asile et le qtf puisque la
disposition que nous vous présenterons
il s'agira de correspondre à la à la
hausse de la campagne du président de la
République le refus d'asile à l'OFPRA ou
à la CNDA en cas d'appel vaudra au Qts
et le tribunal administratif aura 15
jours pour pouvoir juger
l'acte ainsi contesté aujourd'hui une
demande d'asile c'est entre un an et un
an et demi voire deux ans pour avoir une
réponse la loi colon a permis de passer
le travail de l'OFPRA de neuf mois à 5
mois mais la malheureusement pour les
raisons que nous avons évoqué prend un
peu trop de temps en tout cas par manque
de moyens et par manque de
simplification l'idée c'est qu'au moins
de 9 mois la demande d'asile complète de
n'importe quel demandeur d'asile puisse
être jugé d'autres accès de
simplification évidemment lieu je devais
pas les détailler ici de reprennent
largement le rapport du président du C
fait je crois à l'unanimité de votre
assemblée le troisième sujet sur lequel
je voudrais m'appesantir encore les pour
les deux minutes qu'il me reste c'est
celui de l'intégration vous avez voté
dans la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur une
augmentation de 25% du budget
intégration plus de 100 millions d'euros
et notamment de l'apprentissage du
français comme l'a dit la première
ministre 25% des étrangers réguliers sur
notre sol parlent très mal le français
et donc beaucoup de mal à s'intégrer
certes il y a des cours de français
obligatoires mais ils ne sont pas
sanctionnés par un examen qui
conditionnerait le titre de séjour et ce
que nous proposons c'est que les titres
de séjour soient conditionnés à la
réussite et non pas simplement au
passage de l'examen de et à conformément
à ce que nous avons évoqué dans la loi
dit des principes de la République à
l'adhésion des valeurs de la République
et s'il n'y a pas la réussite cet examen
de français c'est quand même pour 270
000 personnes par an que cela serait
organisé et s'il n'y a pas de réussite à
l'examen sur les valeurs de la
République il ne peut pas y avoir de
titre de séjour comme il y a même
l'immigration serait une immigration
familiale c'est évidemment très
important le ministre du Travail
reviendra également sur l'apprentissage
du français dans le cadre du travail des
obligations que nous pourrons imposer ça
demande quelque chose qui n'est pas
législatif mais ça demande quelque chose
qui relève évidemment du travail
réglementaire du travail d'organisation
du ministère de l'Intérieur une
révolution d'organisation des
préfectures qui doivent arrêter de
demander la vérification de type de
séjour de gens qui sont depuis de
nombreuses années sur le sol national
qui travaille et qui n'ont aucun cas
judiciaire il faut que si titres là soit
automatique avec un devoir de rappel de
la part des fonctionnaires en cas de
difficultés ou en cas de casier
judiciaire évidemment de ces personnes
mais ça demande de concentrer
l'intégralité des agents de préfecture
du travail des préfectures d'une part
sur les prix morts-vivants on vérifiez
que ces personnes parlent bien le
français veulent s'intégrer au accès à
un métier puisse faire vivre leur
famille dans des conditions acceptables
d'intégration et également d'expulsion
puisque évidemment il faut améliorer
très largement les exécutions de quitter
le territoire national et comme je l'ai
dit le retrait de titre de séjour aussi
de toute personne qui a quasi judiciaire
j'entaminerai par là mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs depuis 2001 et
depuis la circulaire que j'ai pris à la
demande du Président de la République
92000 titres de séjour ont été refusés
ou retirés pour des étrangers qui
avaient une difficulté avec les règles
de la République on va dire ça comme ça
évidemment désormais l'étape
supplémentaire c'est de pouvoir
s'assurer qu'ils aient quitté le
territoire national pour cela il faut
qu’émones à préfecture arrête d'embêter
administrativement ce qui ne pose aucun
problème à la République et se concentre
plus largement sur ceux qui je suis en
train de la République je crois que
c'est ce que demande les Français merci
Monsieur le Ministre d'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
on est la parole on me suis Éric
Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
ce président madame la Première ministre
monsieur les ministres
monsieur président de la commission des
lois mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
comme la souhaiter madame la Première
ministre le Sénat est aujourd'hui
réunis pour débattre d'un sujet
important un sujet extrêmement complexe
qui peut se résumer au fond d'une
question simple comment et sous quelles
conditions accueillir sur notre sol les
femmes et des hommes de nationalité
étrangères
l'immigration à l'évidence est un
phénomène qu'il faut voir de façon
globale et pragmatique
globale et la question de l'immigration
implique vous le savez de nombreux
périmètres ministériels
comme en témoigne d'ailleurs la présence
de plusieurs de mes collègues
pragmatiques car pour trouver des
solutions il faut se départir de tout
dogmatisme de toutes démagogie et bien
sûr de tout angélisme depuis longtemps
le ministère de la Justice travaille et
tous les autres ministères impliqués sur
la question de l'immigration et plus
particulièrement sur les procédures
administratives et pénales applicables
aux étrangers de quoi parlons-nous
exactement faut tout d'abord réfléchir à
la simplification du traitement du
contentieux des étrangers
je contentieux constitue l'activité
principale des tribunaux administratifs
et des courges administratives d'appel
comme le souligne avec acuité le rapport
Stal publié en 2020 sous l'égide du
Conseil d'État il faut avant tout
rechercher une plus grande efficacité
des mesures juridictionnelles cette
réflexion rejoint celle de l'excellent
rapport du président François nolbuffet
qui dresse
[Musique]
qui dresse un triple constat
droit des étrangers devenus illisible
des procédures
inefficaces et un manque de moyens des
services de l'État pour les mettre en
œuvre
fort de ce diagnostic partagé par toutes
les juridictions administratives par le
menteur
par nous le gouvernement va comme
l'indiquer mon collègue Gérald Darmanin
ouvrir prochainement le chantier de la
réforme du contentieux des étrangers il
n'y aura évidemment aucune question
tabou ainsi la réforme du contentieux de
l'asile devra également être mis à
l'ordre du jour
toutes ces questions sont en débat
aujourd'hui et le seront lors de
l'examen du projet de juin et je sais
bien sûr que vous aurez à coeur de bâtir
une procédure à la fois efficace
respectueuse de nos principes si je
devais en une phrase résumée le propos
la protection des droits et la
protection qu'offre le droit oui bien
sûr
l'instrumentalisation du droit et le
dilatoire non
le second axe de travail que je vous
propose concerne bien sûr la sphère
pénale
laissez-moi tout d'abord insister sur un
constat
il faut le faire lucidement oui bien sûr
il y a des étrangers délinquants oui il
y a des étrangers dans nos prisons de ce
point de vue d'ailleurs la moyenne
qui est la nôtre est une moyenne
européenne mais disons-le l'écrasante
l'écrasante majorité
des personnes que nous accueillons sur
notre sol aime notre pays
et on respecte les lois
et je dis ça avec force parce qu'il ne
faut pas accepter me semble-t-il des
amalgames parfois faciles ou des
généralisations entre immigration et
délinquance et
pour autant monsieur les sénateurs
mesdames messenatrices je me gare de
tout angélisme et je souhaite que nous
puissions dans le cadre du projet de loi
permettre à notre droit pénal d'être
plus efficient à l'égard des étrangers
qui ne respectent ni nos lois ni notre
pacte républicain pour y parvenir il
nous faut réfléchir à un élargissement
de la peine d'interdiction du territoire
français il s'agit aujourd'hui vous le
savez d'une peine complémentaire
prévue dans de nombreuses infractions
qui constituent les infractions les plus
graves crimes contre l'humanité
infraction terroriste atteinte
volontaire à la vie par exemple pourquoi
ne pas harmoniser les conditions
d'interdiction judiciaire du territoire
français avec celle des mesures
d'expulsion n'est-il pas légitime qu'un
juge correctionnel puisse protéger notre
territoire et nos concitoyens aussi bien
qu'un préfet qui décide d'une expulsion
pour un étranger délinquant pourquoi
également ne pas explorer
l'élargissement du champ infractionnel
de cette peine complémentaire avec bien
sûr toutes les précautions qui
s'imposent car cette élargissement ne
pourra avoir lieu sans que soit garantie
les grands principes de l'État de droit
auquel nous sommes tous particulièrement
attachés voilà ces pistes sont
sérieusement à l'étude c'est tout
l'enjeu des débats qui vous attendent
être ferme à l'égard des étrangers qui
s'affranchissent de nos règles tout en
garantissant à chaque femme à chaque
homme qui souhaite s'installer
régulièrement sur notre territoire un
examen ind visualiser de sa situation
personnelle et familiale mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs les Français
nous attendent ils nous regardent il est
dans notre responsabilité collective de
nous montrer à la hauteur de leurs
attentes bien légitimes
merci Monsieur
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Duchamp
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre monsieur les ministres mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs une politique
d'intégration doit naturellement
envisager le travail comme un outil
essentiel pour cette intégration car
c'est à nos yeux le seul moyen durable
pour un étranger arrivant sur notre
territoire d'assurer sa subsistance il
faut aussi souligner rappeler que le
contexte professionnel facilite
grandement l'apprentissage de la langue
et l'apprentissage de la culture d'un
peuple par ailleurs la France comme de
nombreux autres pays a besoin de talents
étrangers cela ne signifie aucunement
que nous sommes délir notre obligation
de former et d'accompagner nos
compatriotes les résidences notre
territoire c'est notre priorité dans
notre marche dans le Pôle emploi mais
cela signifie aussi que nous devons
accompagner cette politique d'un recours
subsidiaire recrutement d'étrangers non
communautaire pour faire face à nos
besoins de compétences en réalité nous
le savons nous avons déjà des procédures
pour permettre l'introduction de main
d'oeuvre étrangères et de talons venus
de l'étranger nous savons aussi délivrer
les titres de séjour à des personnes
présentes depuis plusieurs années sur le
territoire
mais nous ne pouvons pas nous soustraire
plus longtemps à une analyse lucide de
notre système et constater qu'il est
inefficace par plusieurs aspects et
injuste par d'autres
il n'est d'abord pas efficace car il ne
met pas à de nombreux étrangers arrivés
régulièrement sur notre territoire de se
former d'être accompagné pour exercer un
emploi cela se voit dans les chiffres
dans les résultats de la politique de
l'emploi au premier trimestre 2022 le
taux de chômage des personnes étrangères
était de 13% contre 7 et demi pour
l'ensemble de la population et ce
rapport ne varie pas ni en fonction des
crises ni en fonction des périodes de
croissance dans le même temps nous
enfermons aussi dans l'illégalité des
étrangers présents depuis longtemps sur
notre territoire et travaillant
notamment dans des secteurs intentions
ils sont pourtant essentiels à la
prospérité au développement de notre
pays ils sont le plus souvent déclarés
il paye des impôts des cotisations mais
leur situation relève parfois aussi
d'une grande difficulté d'une précarité
et de la traite des êtres humains
l'absence de droit au séjour les rend
vulnérables et précaires il arrive aussi
que des employeurs peu scrupuleux les
oblige à travailler parfois plusieurs
semaines sans repos ou encore être
hébergé dans des conditions indignes
cela ne vaut évidemment pas
généralisation mais nous savons que cela
existe et que ces situations peuvent
présenter aussi progresser sur ce sujet
c'est progresser sur l'ensemble des
conditions de travail en supprimant ces
situations du pire et en revenant un
socle commun pour l'ensemble des
salariés
ce constat si il est partagé nos oblige
et nous devons sortir d'un système
perdant tout en même temps il nous un
combo si de faire davantage pour lutter
contre le travail légal et contre le
travail dissimulé ainsi des étrangers
présents depuis plusieurs années sur le
territoire travaillant depuis plusieurs
mois en France dans un métier en tension
sont en situation régulière est-ce
irrégulière et s'emporte de sortie il
travaille il s'intègre veulent
s'intégrer sont intégrés et ils demeure
pourtant sans droit au séjour ni au
travail nous souhaitons que ces
étrangers puissent obtenir un titre
temporaire pour une année renouvelable
pour leur permettre de travailler
légalement dans les secteurs dans les
secteurs en contrant les plus grandes
pensions de main d'oeuvre ils pourront
ensuite s'insérer dans un parcours plus
classique toujours par le travail et par
la longue ça s'appelle tout simplement
l'intégration et c'est ce que nous
voulons promouvoir comme nous l'avons
indiqué avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
je le dis au passage certains peignent
de pensée que nous allons ainsi
favoriser le travail des étrangers
aurement du travail des Français c'est
faux par construction les secteurs en
question ont besoin de main d'oeuvre ils
en ont déjà besoin je les étrangers dont
nous parlons ne prennent le travail de
personnes ils occupent pas d'emploi sur
lequel il est bien difficile de recruter
et par ailleurs nous n'abandons
évidemment pas l'important est forte de
formation de l'ensemble des actifs et
cet objectif de plein emploi pour tous
de plus qu'introduction de ce type de
séjour est aussi une demande forte de
nombreuses entreprises qui souhaitent
ainsi pouvoir régulariser accompagner la
régularisation de celles et ceux qui
travaillent pour elle dans ce même état
d'esprit nous avons d'ores et déjà
initier la révision de la liste
existante des missions de tension elle
comporte quelques incongrités quelques
manques les métiers de la restauration
ils sont par exemple aujourd'hui peu
présents tout comme ceux de la propreté
or cette liste doit être plus en phase
avec la réalité des tensions de
recrutement
ensuite si nous avons regardé la réalité
en face pour ce qui concerne la part des
emplointes tensions occupées aujourd'hui
par des étrangers en situation régulière
ou irrégulière nous devons aussi
constater la faiblesse ou plutôt la
lenteur des sanctions infligées le
travail illégal est constaté c'est une
certitude la lutte contre le travail
illégal passera par des sanctions plus
facilement et plus rapidement
applicables il existe aujourd'hui des
fonctions pénales que nous ne prévoyons
pas de modifier elles sont nécessaires
au traitement des situations les plus
graves dès lors que l'intentionalité la
dégradation des conditions de travail
sont manifestes il existe aussi des
sanctions administratives par exemple la
possibilité pour les préfets de fermer
l'établissement pour une durée maximale
de trois mois c'est une sanction lourse
que nous devons faciliter il nous faut
aussi une fonction administrative mais
calibrée pour être plus systématique
comme une amende de plusieurs milliers
d'euros pour un emploi illégal elle
n'aurait pas un caractère automatique
mais serait déployé en fonction
d'appréciation d'un certain nombre de
critères tels que les ressources les
charges mais aussi et peut-être surtout
l'intentionnalité le contexte c'est la
gravité enfin je termine par là
l'intégration une évidence le ministre
de l'Intérieur l'a dit se fait aussi par
la langue en cohérence avec cette
exigence de maîtrise de la langue nous
considérons que les employeurs doivent
aussi faciliter l'intégration leurs
salariés étrangés par la langue bien des
employeurs comptent sur la main d'oeuvre
étrangère pour faire tourner leur
entreprise il n'est donc pas normal que
les employeurs puissent contribuer à la
réussite de l'intégration leur salarié
par la langue nous avons ouvert un
dialogue avec les partenaires sociaux
pouvoir comment par les opérateurs de
formation par le financement la
formation continue par la possibilité de
libérer des heures sur le temps de
travail pour participer aux formations
nous pouvons mettre à contribution les
employeurs pour la formation en français
de leurs salarié étrangers nous abordons
ce débattre en aïveté en voulant ne plus
être les complices passifs d'injustice
existantes quant au travail des
étrangers s'en naïveté ni idéalisme mais
avec du réalisme et la volonté de
protéger les travailleurs comme les
chefs d'entreprise qui n'ont pas
d'autres alternatives
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
nous allons aborder maintenant la suite
de nos débats et je vais donner la
parole aux orateurs des groupes tout
d'abord le président François Noël
buffet pour les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues il n'existe
pas le pays qui peut accueillir
l'ensemble des migrants économies qu'il
n'existe pas nous n'avons nous avons
besoin d'améliorer l'intégration dans la
République plus vite et mieux je ne veux
plus de femmes et d'hommes dans les rues
mais partout dès la première minute un
traitement administratif qui permet de
déterminer si on peut aller vers une
demande d'asile ou non et derrière une
vraie politique de reconduite aux
frontières
ces trois phrases ne sont pas les
miennes certains peut-être s'en
souviendront elles ont été prononcées il
y a déjà cinq ans par le Président de la
République lui-même à Orléans
on aurait pu être séduit il y a 5 ans
par ses propos qui semblaient annoncés
une grande ambition de moderniser et
dirais-je de pensées
dans sa globalité notre politique
migratoire mais regardons les choses en
face la triste réalité c'est que notre
politique d'immigration d'asile et
d'intégration est aujourd'hui dans
l'impasse je vous conseille madame la
Première ministre que cette faillite
trouve ses racines dans les armans d'un
quinquennat de Monsieur prendre le
président Hollande dont vous avez en
partie héritée mais force de constater
que 5 ans après le discours à Orléans le
gouvernement n'a pas pu se donner les
moyens de redresser totalement la barre
nous avons d'abord renoncer à la
maîtrise de l'immigration légale dont
chacun sait qu'elle nourrit pour partie
l'immigration irrégulière pour la seule
année 2021 et je reprends les chiffres
publiés en juin 2022 par le ministère de
l'Intérieur 270
000 premiers titres de séjour ont été
délivrés en France métropolitaine cent
mille de plus comme 2011 le stock des
titres valides à lui grimper de 1
million pour atteindre aujourd'hui 3
millions 400 000 l'ampleur de ces
chiffres et de leur évolution par
d'elle-même certains sur ces bancs
soutiendront que l'immigration est une
chance pour les pays européens sans
doute mais à condition que cette
immigration soit un apport pour ce pays
et non une charge or comme le souligne
l'OCDE la contribution de l'immigration
à la société et l'économie d'un pays
quel qu'il soit et étroitement lié à son
niveau de qualification et le niveau de
qualification constaté en France et bien
moindre que chez nos voisins européens
quant à l'intégration elle ne peut
véritablement advenir qu'avec la
maîtrise de notre langue et le respect
des principes et des valeurs qui font
notre nation alors vous l'avez dit vous
même la semaine dernière monsieur news
de l'intérieur un quart des étrangers en
situation irrégulière parlent ou
écrivent très mal le français côté
immigration irrégulière nous allons
d'échec en échec avec d'abord une
maîtrise insuffisante de nos frontières
je veux dire presque aujourd'hui presque
nos frontières européennes si ça ne fait
Miss en 2006 sur ces mêmes bancs le
gouvernement de l'époque estimait le
nombre de clandestins présents sur le
territoire national entre 200 et 400 000
devant la commission des lois le 2
novembre dernier vous avez monsieur le
ministre évalué ce chiffre entre 600 000
et 900 000 il a donc multiplié par au
moins 2 en 15 ans et la potion est
encore plus amère s'agissant de
l'éloignement
le taux d'exécution des eqtf se situe
selon les chiffres transmis par le
ministère un niveau familiique de 6,9%
au premier semestre 2022 on peut
toujours discuter la pertinence de ce
taux mais nous ne pouvons pas nous ne
pouvons que constater un indicateur
constant nous exécutions encore 22% de
nos hôpitaux en 2012 3 fois plus
qu'aujourd'hui s'il y a lieu du côté de
l'asile ensuite nous sommes en s'il y a
mieux pardon du milieu du côté de
l'asile ensuite nous sommes encore loin
du compte avec un délai moyen d'examen
des demandes d'un peu plus de 330 au
jour aujourd'hui l'objectif de six mois
fiction 2017 est hors de portée à moyen
terme c'est de plus regrettable que nous
renouons avec les niveaux exceptionnels
des demandes connues avant la pandémie
nous devrions même dépasser l'année
prochaine le record de 2019 avec 135 000
demandes attendues
je n'adresse pas madame la Première
ministre ce tableau ni par malice ni par
fatalisme car se laisser aller à l'une
ou à l'autre ce serait renoncé à
chercher des solutions pour se réfugier
derrière des postures stériles ce serait
alimenté ce serait alimenté chez nos
concitoyens des peurs qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être et ce serait surtout ouvrir la
porte en grand aux extrêmes vous l'avez
dit à l'Assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière la dernière ministre si nous
voulons débattre sérieusement de la
politique migratoire nous devons nous
astreindre à un langage de vérité un
langage de vérité appuyé sur des données
partagées et indiscutables qui affirme
le constat lucide d'une immigration qui
n'est pas maîtrisée et d'une politique
publique qui a perdu tout son sens un
langage de vérité qui énonce clairement
les objectifs à atteindre et dénoncent
les postures l'immigration zéro est une
chimère l'accueil au fil de l'eau est
une folie
dans ce contexte ce qui nous fait
aujourd'hui cruellement défaut c'est en
réalité une réelle stratégie migratoire
car faute d'anticipation il faute de
volonté clairement exprimer nous ne
faisons que subir les soubresauts des
flux migratoires nous avons été dépassés
par l'intensité des flux en 2015 nous
sommes encore aujourd'hui avec la
reprise postokovide le nom de vivre
encore un événement très particulier
avec l'océan de Viking notamment dans
les conditions dans lesquelles les
procédures ont été suivies tellement
complexes ce n'est pourtant pas un gros
mot que de dire que comme tout État
souverain c'est à nous qu'il revient de
dire qui nous accueillons sur notre
territoire et qu'il n'y a pas sa place
pour nous il y a trois principes le
premier une immigration régulière
choisie prioritairement économique et
qui trouvera d'autant plus sa place dans
notre société qui a les contribuera
pleinement
la deuxième de l'intransigeance dans la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
et le troisième de l'efficacité dans
l'application de la procédure d'asile
voilà les trois piliers sur lesquels
doit reposer une semble-t-il notre
stratégie migratoire ces stratégie c'est
celle que défend le Sénat en tous les
cas sa majorité depuis de nombreuses
années c'était le sens des propositions
que nous avions portées de l'examen de
la loi Colomb en 2018 et qui ont été
pour partie balayer d'un revers de main
par l'exécutif à l'époque je constate
néanmoins avec satisfaction plus qu'une
infection de la part du gouvernement qui
envisage désormais de reprendre
plusieurs de nos propositions dans le
texte qui devrait venir devant le Sénat
premier lecture nous vous en remercions
au mois de mars prochain certaines
pistes du gouvernement peuvent être
intéressantes d'autres sont moins
acceptables mais j'y reviendrai
vous rappelez régulièrement vous êtes
inspiré pour la rédaction de votre texte
du rapport service de l'État immigration
retrouver sens et efficacité que votre
serviteur a rédigé au mois de mai
dernier c'est je dois le dire bien un
bon début mais pour éviter tout
malentendu et comme l'on n'est jamais
mieux servi que par soi-même je vais
vous faire des propositions assez
concrètes ancré dans les positions
constamment soutenues par le Sénat
depuis plus de 10 ans et qui vise à
doter la France d'une stratégie
migratoire réellement ambitieuse et
efficace madame la Première ministre
vous avez déploré la semaine dernière
devant l'Assemblée nationale le manque
de proposition les nôtres vont être sur
la table permettez-moi de vous en
présenter quelques grandes lignes
la première priorité est de retrouver
notre souveraineté en matière
d'immigration régulière décider qui l'on
accueille sur le territoire en assumant
de prioriser l'immigration économique
pour mémoire celles-ci représentait à
peine 13% des premiers titres le séjour
délivré en 2021 c'est au Parlement qu'il
revient de fixer ses orientations
annuelles avec disons le franchement le
débat sur des quotas ou en tous les cas
de grandes orientations
recouvrez notre souveraineté c'est aussi
assumé de restreindre les voies d'accès
au séjour je pense à la procédure
étrangée malades pour laquelle il est
urgent de revenir aux critères de
l'absence de soins dans le pays
d'origine rien que pour 2021 nous avons
reçu 5000 demandes émanant des pays du
G20 qui disposent pourtant le système de
soins développés je pense aussi aux
regroupement familial pour lequel nous
proposons de resserrer les critères
naturellement dans le respect du droit
européen
mais avoir une politique d'immigration
régulière cohérente c'est aussi mieux
traiter ce que nous acceptons sur notre
territoire je ne reviens pas sur les
situations ubuesque générées par les
difficultés au guichet des préfectures
pour obtenir ou renouveler un titre de
séjour la solution est pourtant là avec
une refonte des pratiques d'instructions
autour d'une logique dites 360° que
votre gouvernement a expertisé ou
auprès de la préfecture d'Angers pardon
où l'on examinerait dès la première
demande et une fois pour toute
l'ensemble des motifs qui pourraient
fonder la délivrance d'un titre de
séjour est une très bonne démarche mieux
traiter les étrangers en situation
régulière demande également de muscler
notre dispositif d'intégration ou
proposer monsieur le ministre
d'augmenter le volume d'or de français
et c'est une bonne chose la contrepartie
c'est le renforcement des devoirs de
l'étranger vous avez repris la
proposition du Sénat de conditionner la
délivrance des titres de séjour de
longue durée à la réussite un examen de
langue fort bien nous estimons
nécessaires vous allez encore plus loin
et de la conditionner également à la
réussite d'un examen civique pour lequel
l'étranger démontrerait sa bonne
appréciation des valeurs de notre
histoire et de la culture de la
République de la France passer une
logique de moyens à une logique de
résultats ce jeu de croix la vraie
révolution pour le contrat d'intégration
républicaine
cette appropriation des valeurs
républicaines n'est pas négociable et
l'obtention d'un titre de séjour n'est
pas un blanc saint elle vient avec des
responsabilités à cet égard nous aurons
quelques difficultés à vous suivre dans
votre idée d'automaticité de
renouvellement de titre pluraluels en
tous les cas à ce stade attendons de
voir le texte lui-même la deuxième
priorité c'est fluidifier le traitement
des demandes d'asile et de lutter plus
efficacement contre le détournement de
notre politique d'accueil il est crucial
de faciliter l'instruction des demandes
de protection internationale en
permettant notamment à l'OFPRA de
statuer plus rapidement sur les dossiers
les moins problématiques par exemple en
cas de retrait de la demande ou
d'abandon du lieu d'hébergement mais
aussi en lui imposant de refuser l'asile
en cas de menace pour l'ordre public ce
faisant l'office pourra concentrer son
expertise sur les dossiers les plus
complexes je tiens à cet instant à cette
tribune à saluer le travail qui est fait
par le PRA et la qualité des agents qui
travaillent au sein de cette de cette
institution enfin
nous nous devons de faire de la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière une
priorité nationale et d'agir enfin pour
la mise en œuvre des décisions
d'éloignement
prévenir l'immigration irrégulière c'est
d'abord assumer d'établir un rapport de
force avec les états d'origine le Sénat
avait voté en 2018 une disposition
autorisant les restrictions de visa à
l'égard des pays délivrant peu de
laisser passer consulaire le
gouvernement à l'époque ne l'avait pas
retenu ici est finalement résolu et là
encore cela a produit quelques résultats
puisque le nombre de retours forcés vers
l'Algérie certes modeste en volume ont
malgré tout été multiplié par 16 en
moins d'un an
la montée en puissance de la lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine ne se
fera pas non plus sans réforme de l'aide
médicale d'État avec 400 000
bénéficiaires et un coût supérieur à 1
milliard d'euros celle-ci atteint des
sommets nous ne pouvons pas nous
satisfaire des derniers ajustements
paramétriques c'est une des réformes
structurelles dont nous avons besoin là
encore le Sénat défend de longue date
sont remplacement par une aide médicale
d'urgence centrée sur la prise en charge
des pathologies les plus graves l'ame
madame la Premier ministre se justifie
pour des raisons de santé publique mais
on ne peut obérer le fait qu'elle
constitue aussi parfois une incitation à
l'immigration irrégulière il en va de
même du projet des titres de séjour
métier en tension qui est une opération
de régularisation finalement qui ne sait
pas dire son nom soyons clairs qu'est-ce
que l'attribution d'un titre de séjour à
une personne en situation irrégulière
sinon une régularisation la
problématique pourtant est réelle je
veux le dire à cette tribune la
situation est bien réelle nous ne
pouvons nier que nombre de métiers
parfois indispensables sont exercées en
majorité par les étrangers et nous
pouvons en débattre la solution pastel
pour autant par une régularisation
massive sans aucun ciblage au risque de
créer un nouvel appel d'air je pense que
non et nous savons tous que dans ces
conditions-là si cela devait être le cas
les affaires des filières criminelles
qui industrialisent le passage des
clandestins et joue avec leur vie se
formentaient immédiatement mais il
faudra il faudra des critères il faudra
des conditions il faudra préciser les
choses dans la loi parce que la
problématique est bien existante et
depuis le début je dis qu'il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont telles
qu'on les aimerait tel que vous les
niret c'est également le cas de la
réforme du contentieux nous le savons
tous le droit des étrangers est une
complexité qui frôle l'absurde il suffit
de voir le col de ceséda la taille qu'il
a pris c'est une charge pour les
magistrats chargés de l'appliquer une
source d'insécurité juridique pour les
justiciables et une aubaine le
clandestin cherchant à se soustraire à
l'éloignement le Gouvernement a souhaité
réduire à 4 le nombre de procédures
contentieuses nous proposons descendre
jusqu'à 3 mais la discussion se fera
naturellement nous sommes pas là pour
discuter de ces points de détails en
tous les cas mais madame la Première
ministre avant de terminer mon propos je
voudrais vous dire que je pense que ce
n'est pas en masquant les problèmes que
l'on va les oublier ce n'est pas en les
nommant que l'on va les aggraver mais
c'est certainement avec des propositions
concrètes qu'on arrivera à les résoudre
cela tombe bien n'en manquons pas celle
que je vous ai exposées et bien d'autres
feront part de nous serons dans nos
propositions il y a eu 21 lois
immigration en 30 ans ce qui fait à peu
près une tous les 16 mois je vous
propose que nous prenions l'engagement
de doter notre pays d'une vraie
stratégie en tous les cas pour notre
groupe nous y sommes prêts merci merci
[Applaudissements]
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains j'ai donné la parole à
notre collègue Jean-Yves Leconte
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre messieurs les
ministres
l'asile est un droit c'est un engagement
en conventionnel et c'est aussi une part
de notre identité constitutionnelle
l'immigration c'est autre chose c'est
une politique qui me convient de mener
en respectant nos principes et en
respectant aussi au mieux les intérêts
de notre pays
avant 2018 jamais ces deux sujets
n'avaient été abordés dans les mêmes
lois parce que ce sont deux sujets
distinctes malheureusement maintenant
nous devons les aborder ensemble nous
vous constater que la question de
l'immigration est un sujet sur les
Français semblent relativement fermés
entre guillemets lorsque la question
leur est posée d'une manière globale
mais par contre ils sont
fondamentalement ouverts et généreux dès
lors qu'ils font face à des situations
concrètes et ils sont attachés à notre
tradition d'accueil et d'asile rappelons
quelques fêtes la France est restée
relativement à l'écart des grands
mouvements de demandes de protection que
ce soit au moment de la crise syrienne
ou au moment de actuellement avec la
crise ukrainienne nous ne sommes pas le
pays qui en avons accueilli le plus
d'ukrainien
deuxièmement nous délivrons finalement
relativement peu de premier titre de
séjour tous les ans par rapport à des
pays de taille similaires avec une
économie de tels de même nature enfin
plutôt que de penser que
l'émigrations croisent de manière
exponentielle au début du 20e siècle
5% de la population mondiale était
migrante aujourd'hui c'est moins de 3,5
%. enfin l'immigration familiale en
France elle n'est pas open bar il faut
plus de 18 mois de présence en France et
des conditions précises de ressources et
de logements madame la Première ministre
sur ce gouvernement
sur ce sujet c'est la politique du
désordre et de l'affichage désordre des
préfectures dysfonctionnelles où il est
impossible de prendre rendez-vous des
personnes en situation irrégulière qui
deviennent irrégulières parce qu'elles
ne peuvent pas avoir de documents
renouvelés 50% de la justice
administrative des mobilisée sur ces
dysfonctionnements qui coûtent à l'état
et vous aurez vous à vous annoncer
monsieur le Premier monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur un renouvellement
automatique comment cela va-t-il se
passer réellement désordre lorsque
depuis vous êtes monsieur intérieur
ministre depuis deux ans rien n'est fait
pour régler la question des personnes
qui sont ni expulsables ni
régularisables il faut absolument faire
un examen à 360 degrés de l'ensemble des
situations et pour cela il faut du
personnel désordre lorsque lors d'une
préfecture à l'autre
nous ne se prêtons pas de la même
manière les demandes des examens de
demande d'admission exceptionnelle au
séjour parfois même c'est impossible
désordre lorsque pour le chiffre et
l'affichage monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vous exigez pour des préfets
plus de ITF alors qu'il devrait se
contenter de se concentrer sur ce qui
est faisable en premier lieu sur les
personnes qui représentent réellement un
risque pour l'ordre public et pas
simplement lorsqu'elles sont inscrites
au Tage à vouloir faire du chiffre on ne
fait pas correctement l'essentiel vous
instrumentalisez instrumentaliser les
dublinets pour faire du chiffre ils
reviennent une semaine après et les
personnels de la PAF ils ont perdu
absolument le sens de leur action vous
avez des cras qui sont vous fixez
l'objectif de de
remplir 90% mais monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur des CRA qui fonctionne ce
sont des craints ou les personnes qui
sont retenues sont les personnes qui
peuvent être éloignés
désordre lorsque vous rappelez le
rapport Stal lorsque vous appelez à
simplifier le droit des étrangers et
nous sommes d'accord avec cela mais
alors pourquoi annoncer un acte
administratif comme une occultéef dès
lors que le frein refuserait une
protection ce serait un acte
administratif qui nous aurait donné que
le nom si nous respectons la Convention
de Genève des ordres aussi lorsque c'est
défaillances de l'État pèsent sur
l'intégration lorsqu'elle pète
lorsqu'elle conduisent les personnes à
s'appuyer sur leur communauté plutôt que
sur les services publics et font peser
le devoir d'humanité sur les
collectivités locales et sur les
associations monsieur le ministre
j'arrête les choses désagréables je
constate une évolution entre l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat à l'Assemblée
nationale vous aviez évoqué que vous ne
mettrez plus encras des personnes de
moins de 16 ans vous avez précisé ici
que ça s'adopterait à tous les mineurs
je salue cette évolution en une semaine
il faut aussi saluer que pour la
première fois depuis longtemps
ces questions ne pas se sont pas
exclusivement des questions du ministère
de l'intérieur parce qu'une intégration
réussie elle passe monsieur Eve ça a été
rappelé monsieur le ministre monsieur et
madame la Première ministre par le
travail elle passe par le travail elle
passe par l'école historiquement c'est
ainsi que ça s'est passé en France et on
doit constater que grâce aux deux plus
grands mouvements actuels au Venezuela
avec la Colombie et l'Ukraine avec
l'Union européenne dans les deux cas les
accueils se font avec une reconnaissance
du statut tout de suite et le droit au
travail tout de suite c'est la meilleure
manière de faire et le droit au travail
c'est la meilleure manière d'éviter le
dopping social la meilleure le droit au
travail c'est la meilleure manière de
liquider l'esclavage moderne dont nous
sommes témoins chaque jour dans des
actes essentiels de la vie
et vous avez madame la Première ministre
énormément de marge de manœuvre pour
faire beaucoup plus que ce que vous avez
fait au cours des dernières années sans
changer la loi d'abord la liste des
métiers d'attention elle n'a bougé
qu'une fois en 2021 depuis 2008
deuxièmement les situations de jeunes
apprentis en situation irrégulière qui
choquent la population et bien elles ne
sont pas mieux résolues aujourd'hui
qu'elles ne les taillaient à quelques
années enfin
mes chers collègues la France est dans
l'espace Schengen c'est un espace de
libre circulation et une commission
d'enquête du Sénat il y a quelques
années à rappeler l'intérêt et l'utilité
de cette espace de libre circulation dès
lors qu'il y avait entre nos pays des
échanges d'information solides et la
confiance et d'autre part une
surveillance sérieuse des frontières
extérieures et nous avons entre 2012 et
réformer l'interopylate parabilité des
systèmes mis en place le PNR lancer le
projet Ethias et renforcer le mandat de
Frontex l'Europe sur ces questions n'est
pas un problème c'est une solution
chaque État doit donc respecter le droit
européen le pacte asile migration avocat
renforcé encore la cohérence de cette
action et ce que nous avons constaté
l'année dernière avec ce qui se passait
à la frontière des Pays-Bas et de la
Pologne avec la Biélorussie souligne
qu'il peut y avoir des nouvelles
arrivées des nouvelles situations
imprévues qui méritent d'être de manière
construite solidaire entre les pays
européens mais cela oblige chaque pays
européen à respecter le droit européen
le droit européen l'Italie elle doit
respecter le droit de la mer mais la
France elle doit le respecter aussi le
droit européen lorsqu'il s'agit de
respecter le fait que en Europe il y a
la libre circulation et on ne peut pas
systématiquement remettre en place des
contrôles aux frontières intérieures de
l'Union la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne la correctement rappelé et il
est important de respecter le droit
européen si on veut elle a rappelé au
Conseil d'État autrichien monsieur le
ministre vous voulez pas l'entendre mais
regardez ce qui se passe avec l'Autriche
la politique de visa monsieur le
ministre que vous avez mis en place en
particulier depuis quelques mois
qu'est-ce que c'est des délais
incroyables des refus arbitraire des
projets de vie détruit voilà aujourd'hui
une politique de visa qui détruit
progressivement les liens historiques
que nous avons avec les pays du Sud de
la Méditerranée ce n'est plus Paris mais
Istanbul Dubaï même parfois Moscou qui
sont référence aux yeux de beaucoup et
nous n'avons qu'un enfant qu'à
nous-mêmes et à votre politique dans de
très nombreux pays les communautés se
plaignent de contrats qui ne peuvent
plus être conclus de visite inks peuvent
plus être faites cela doit cesser plus
de 17000 morts en Méditerranée au cours
des six dernières années des milliers
d'enfants disparus sur la route des
Balkans monsieur le ministre madame la
Première ministre cela doit cesser la
lutte contre les passeurs n'est pas
compatible avec le financement de
structurer opaque où je trouve tels que
les gardes contre les gardes frontières
libyens obtenir des laissés passer
consulaires lorsque cela est nécessaire
ne peut pas se faire dans un d'une
démarche de coups de menton elle doit se
paraisser dans une démarche bien
comprise avec les pays d'origine et de
transit une démarche qui doit donner une
place significative à des politiques de
mobilité légale
enfin la ville qui depuis notre
révolution est au cœur de notre identité
elle était essentielle cette politique
les personnes qui méritent d'être
protégées
elles viennent après avoir vécu des
chocs terribles elle ne peuvent pas être
en mesure en quelques jours de préparer
leur récit correctement alors monsieur
le ministre que vous annoncez un guichet
français très bien
mais auront-elles le temps de se
préparer deuxièmement vous nous annoncez
une réforme de la CNDA nous refusons le
juge unique systématique nous ne voulons
pas que la chair soit mis en dehors des
CNDA et nous considérons aussi qu'il
faut avancer sur une reconnaissance sur
une reconnaissance européenne des
instructions des demandes d'asile et
cela doit passer par une Cour européenne
du droit d'asile enfin il est essentiel
qu'aucune minute ne soit perdue pour une
personne qui entend demander îles pour
lui reconnaître le droit au travail le
droit à la formation et le droit à
l'apprentissage de la langue aucune
minute ne doit être perdu pour lui
donner la possibilité d'être autonome le
plus vite possible enfin
il y a encore beaucoup de choses à dire
en particulier sur les questions liées à
l'outre-mer
mais si nous sommes une république il
n'y a qu'un seul territoire sur lequel
il n'y a qu'une seule loi la situation à
Mayotte est très compliquée mais il
acceptable qu'un titre de séjour à
Mayotte ne donne pas le droit de voyager
dans l'Hexagone toutes les larmes qui
sont versées sur Mayotte de son qui
pochésie si les étrangers qui sont en
situation régulière à Mayotte ne peuvent
pas tous venir en France s'ils le
souhaitent
voilà une politique humaine cohérente et
résolue profondément européenne avec ce
type de politique nous pouvons retrouver
la voie de la confiance en nous-mêmes
corriger nos erreurs afin de récupérer
une capacité d'intégrer celles et ceux
qui viennent se réfugier viennent
travailler et étudier en France et il
contribue ensuite à l'édification de
notre pays c'est ainsi que notre pays
s'est construit grâce à des apports à
des diversités étrangères et c'est avec
cette force et avec cette volonté que
nous pouvons continuer si nous avons
confiance en nous si nous avons
confiance dans notre histoire si nous
avons confiance dans nos principes et si
nous avons confiance et nous donnons
confiance à l'Europe je vous remercie
paroles que notre collègue Philippe
voncareire sur le groupe de l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre messieurs les ministres
l'immigration met en tension la
souveraineté qui fonde l'Etat et la
citoyenneté qui font de la Nation avec
mes collègues centrices nous souhaitons
présenter nos propositions
d'enlever les bref un parti elles seront
cursives et je m'indexus par avance nous
ne partageons pas l'idée suivant
laquelle l'action de l'exécutif serait
empêché ou interdite par l'État droit
les deux sont compatibles aussi nous
nous ferons aucune proposition de nature
constitutionnelle
le premier niveau de solution est
européen la révision du paquet agile est
un échec pro le nom durable relevons
quelques avancées avec la montée en
puissance de Frontex la création de
l'Agence européenne pour les îles avec
l'objectif d'harmoniser les politiques
en particulier la liste des pays d'issus
nous proposons une reconnaissance
mutuelle des décisions de rejet d'une
demande d'asile afin d'éviter les
migrations dites de rebond si cet
objectif n'est pas atteignable à 27 il
pourrait l'être par une coopération
renforcée madame le Premier ministre à
partir de 9 états ou par des accords
bilatéraux nous souhaitons aussi
l'entrée en vigueur effectivement 2023
monsieur misen intérieur du système
entrée-sortie système dit ees enfin
robuste avec la précision qu'encadre
refus de se soumettre au relevé
d'empreintes l'intéresser se verrait
refuser l'accès au territoire européen
pour revenir en France la première voie
d'immigration et familiale outil du
droit à la vie privée nous faisons deux
propositions portez de 18 à 24 mois le
délai de présence régulière sur le
territoire à partir duquel pourrait être
faite la demande de rapprochement c'est
le délai plafond fixé par la directive
de 2003 la deuxième proposition consiste
à explorer les mesures conditionnelles
visées par la directive de 2003 à savoir
disposer de ressources suffisantes dans
le logement le respect de l'ordre public
est fait pour la personne faisant
l'objet de la demande de rapprochement
de se conformer aux mesures dites
d'intégration chaque mot à son
importance nous pensons en particulier à
la maîtrise préalable de la langue
française au-dessus du contrat
d'intégration mais je reconnais bien
volontiers que notre collègue François
de Noël buffet eu raison d'évoquer tout
à l'heure la connaissance de la culture
française
si nous mettons à part les visas
étudiants qui me semblent pas faire de
difficultés la deuxième voie
d'immigration et celle des permis de
séjour votre proposition majeure madame
la Première ministre monsieur et
ministre porte sur un permis de séjour
pour les métiers en tension nous serions
favorables à des permis de séjour pour
des métiers en tension
qualifiés qualifié chacun est conscient
de cette vieille pratique française
tando va te confier les métiers que nos
concitoyens ne souhaitent pas assurer à
bas prix à des étrangers
avec ce système rien ne changera c'est
une trappe à bas salaire assurée ces
métiers ne seront jamais attractifs
financièrement pour nos concitoyens ne
monteront pas en qualification en gamme
ne feront l'objet d'aucun investissement
d'automatisation les basses à l'air
entraînent des problèmes de logement la
nécessité de faire appel aux autres
ressortissants du pays d'origine et nous
sommes repartis vers du communautarisme
mes chers collègues
l'idée d'une main d'oeuvre immigrée bon
marché sans cesse renouveler
et nuisible à notre pays
rémunéré renouvelez lorsqu'elle est
nécessaire elle peut être positive
notre opposition serait de vous suivre
madame bremière monsieur les ministres à
condition que le salaire versé soit
également supérieure à la moyenne des
salaires payés dans notre pays ou à
minima dans la branche concernée ceci
nous semblerait aussi le gage d'une
bonne intégration notre groupe est aussi
favorable à ce qui vous a été présenté
tout à l'heure un débat annuel ou
biennal sur les objectifs en matière de
permis de séjour qu'une sorte notre sens
à aucun obstacle constitutionnel les
Français ont un effet leur mot à dire et
c'est la responsabilité de la
représentation nationale c'est votre
responsabilité chers collègues de
l'exprimer nous vous suivons aussi sur
la conditionnalité des visas voir de
l'aide au développement sur la demande
d'asile nous serions ouverts à la
possibilité pour le demandeur de
travailler sans attendre un délai de six
mois une manière même si l'objet de la
demande d'asile est différent de si je
peux me permettre sa capacité à
s'intégrer
nous nous suivons pas
du par contre sur une approche que je
qualifierais de communicante le a les
vert monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
pour le froid et la CNDA l'offrage fait
de gros progrès dans ces délais de
traitement et nous espérons que
l'objectif de traitement à 60 jours pour
être respecté nous doutons qu'il le
serait si vous commencez à saupoudrer
des agents de l'OFPRA dans les
préfectures les officiers dit de
protection instructeurs sont des
spécialistes cette expertise ne veut pas
être fragmentée et le froid il perdrait
un efficacité de même l'idée d'éclater
la CNDA je module de la territorialiser
pour reprendre vos mots monsieur médises
l'intérieur tout à l'heure nous paraît
tout aussi improductive il est
extrêmement difficile de faire coïncider
dans la vraie vie tel type de dossier
concernant des ressortissants de tel
pays avec la présence de tel interprète
et de tels
spécialisés dans le traitement des
ressortissants du DP la CND
effectivement le maillon faible de la
chaîne et nous sommes de la chaîne de
l'asile et nous sommes très loin de
l'objectif de 5 mois prévu sur un
procédure classique et de 5 semaines en
procédure accélérée vous proposez des
audiences à jujunique et de suspites et
des systématiser les visios audiences
nous sommes réservés sur le premier
point mais très favorable au second qui
est à notre sens la clé d'un traitement
dans les délais raisonnables le Conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas conditionné la
tenue d'une vision audience à l'accord
du demandeur d'asile et c'est pourtant
ce qui a été obtenu par les avocats dans
un protocole dit d'expérimentation tout
ceci passe à notre sens par une
négociation de chez le garde des sceaux
avec la profession d'avocats nous sommes
sceptiques à l'idée d'inau qtf dès le
rejet par le froid vous envoyant mal
qu'elle pourrait être l'efficacité
pratique puisque de toute façon il y
aurait une possibilité de recours et
préférions qu'une décision de rejet par
la CNDA fois elle a sorti de plein droit
de l'oktf sans avoir besoin de saisir
l'autorité préfectorale sur la dernière
catégorie d'immigration les
régularisations de la circulaire dites
Vans nous rappelons ce qui a déjà été
voté par le Sénat à savoir que la seule
condition d'une résidence de plus de 5
ans en France ne devrait pas être la
seule condition de la régularisation sur
la question de la grouignement nous
approuvons ce qui a été dit par tous la
simplification du contentieux dans la
dans la logique de accepter de accepter
le président François Noel buffet de
l'excellent un rapport que vous avez
rédigé nous souhaiterions également une
évaluation de la pratique des
certificats d'hébergement fournis au
soutien des visas de long séjour est-ce
qu'il existe une harmonisation des
pratiques dans notre pays quel est le
niveau de contrôle c'est un sujet pour
lequel la participation des
collectivités locales est nécessaire
nous pensons madame la Première ministre
mes chers serait aussi
utile cette participation des
collectivités locales sur le contrat
d'intégration républicain auxquelles
nous sommes justement manqués cette
dimension locale pour s'assurer de la
réalité et des résultats sur la question
de l'aide médicale d'État un classique
du Sénat nous sommes peut-être plus
réservés que certains de nos collègues
quant à l'idée de la modifier une
nouvelle fois nous pensons que sa
limitation aux soins dit nécessaire et
correcte il n'y a pas de grande
différence entre nécessaire et urgent
elle est aussi complétée par un délai de
carence par contre nous suggérons comme
la formule président du fait et je
voudrais insister là-dessus de regarder
une procédure méconnue celle dite de
l'étranger malade par lequel notre pays
offre une faculté de permis de séjour
avec des accompagnants quand la
possibilité d'apporter les soins
satisfaisants n'existent pas dans le
pays d'origine c'est une exception
française chers collègues aucun autre
pays ne la pratique à travers le monde
et elle est aguichée ouvert c'est le
terme même figurant dans le rapport de
l'oshi nous suggérons de conditionner la
procédure d'étrangers malade à une
convention trèsable entre le système
social français et le système social du
pays d'origine nous sommes également
ouverts à la proposition bien connue du
président buffet d'une peine
complémentaire qu'il est détaillée en
d'autres temps et monsieur le garde des
sourd un a tracé aussi quelques éléments
aussi je me permettrai de
[Musique]
conclure cette trop rapide présentation
mes chers collègues vous l'avez compris
pour les sénateurs sont tristes
l'immigration n'a pas vocation à être en
fond de commerce politique mais être
régulé pour que le contrat social qui
structure la France reste solide c'est
le sens de notre proposition madame
Premier ministre monsieur les ministres
et le sera demain de novembre
merci
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue de président François Patriat
du rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ce débat
de bonne tenue auxquelles nous vendent
participer était nécessaire nous
remercions le gouvernement de l'avoir
inscrit à l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée
ce débat mes chers collègues il est
l'occasion de regarder en face la
question migratoire et cela en toute
objectivité nous devons tenir un
discours de vérité aux Français un
discours loin des caricatures est loin
des procès d'intention
dire la vérité c'est d'avoir admettre
que oui l'immigration régulière et
régulière est en progression mais non la
France n'est pas confrontée un tsunami
migratoire ce chauffeur ces chiffons
rouges est agité par l'extrême droite
dans le seul but d'attiser les peurs et
la colère et de diviser les Français le
démographe François errant décrit la
situation de notre pays en disant un
nombre d'immigrés en hausse mais pas en
pointe une immigration familiale
contenue un essor important des
étudiants internationaux des
régularisations en nombre limité et je
voudrais à cette époque dire à ceux qui
alimente le fantasme du Grand
remplacement je voudrais le rappeler que
la proportion d'immigrés dans notre pays
avoue les 10% et nettement inférieur à
la moyenne des pays de l'OCDE loin du
raz-de-marée décrit par les idéologues
xénophobes dire la vérité mes chers
collègues c'est aussi reconnaître que
plusieurs défis restent à relever que ce
soit pour renforcer la maîtrise
migratoire ou pour améliorer l'accueil
des réfugiés et la perception des
Français sur Les migration il y va du
maintien de notre cohésion sociale et de
la préservation de notre pacte
républicain 4 défis majeurs sont devenus
d'abord préserver notre régime d'asile
ensuite renforcer la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière en progression
continue depuis 20 ans en troisième lieu
améliore les conditions d'accueil des
primo arrivants à commencer par les
conditions d'accès au guichet des
préfectures et enfin peut-être même
surtout faciliter l'intégration des
réfugiés et des étrangers en situation
régulière contrairement à ce que
certains affirment la politique du
gouvernement et de sa majorité est
lisible et cohérente depuis 2017 deux
principes guides notre action à la fois
l'humanité et la fermeté l'humanité avec
les étrangers nécessitant une protection
fermeté avec ceux qui n'ont pas vocation
à demeurer sur notre territoire c'est la
cohérence qui amène le gouvernement à
maintenir ce diptyque dans le texte nous
serons bientôt saisies j'ai cru
comprendre madame le Premier ministre et
notre groupe le salut sans surprise les
premières propositions ont déjà été
esquissés nous n'ont pas aussitôt
esquissé que les oppositions sont vite
emparées pour les dénaturer les
caricaturer ou les transformer en contre
vérité j'invite nos collègues aminor et
leurs attaques sur les auqtf chers
collègues ayez l'honnêteté de
reconnaître que le taux d'exécution des
OQTF n'a jamais dépassé 20% toute
période confondues y compris lorsque
chacun d'entre nous était au pouvoir
aussi l'honnêteté de reconnaître que la
faiblesse du taux d'exécution des occqf
est avant tout lié à la difficulté
d'obtenir des laisser passer consulaires
elle est là la vérité d'ailleurs je
salue les efforts déployés par la France
pour convaincre les pays d'origine et de
transit de délivrer ces précieux sésame
ce travail de conviction commence à
porter ses fruits j'aurais préféré que
nous nous faisons félicitons ensemble
plutôt que d'entendre certains camper
sur des positions partisanes je déplobe
d'autant plus que le gouvernement
propose de s'inspirer du rapport du
président buffet dont j'ai apprécié les
propos tout à l'heure pour améliorer
l'efficacité de la lutte contre
l'immigrations clandestine je déplore
aussi que ça donne nos collègues de la
majorité fassent preuve d'autant de
dogmatisme sur le futur titre de séjour
des métiers en tension notre groupe
accueille très positivement cette
proposition qui relève du bon sens non
ce nouveau titre de séjour ne participe
pas d'un soi-disant projet de
résignation nationale et non il
n'entraînera pas d'appel d'air nous en
sommes convaincus cette mesure est
équilibrée régularisée au cas par cas
les travailleurs étrangers déjà présents
sur notre territoire donc déjà intégré
dans notre société et dans le même temps
durcir les sanctions à l'encontre les
employeurs d'étrangers clandestins j'ai
entendu dire ces propositions et le
gouvernement j'ai entendu les
propositions au café tout à l'heure
notre collègue et non buffet mais par
ailleurs j'avais compris aussi dans les
propos la première ministre qu'il y
avait déjà répondu positivement par
avance plutôt que de lancer des procès
d’attention contre cette idée tâchons
plutôt de réfléchir à la manière de les
perfectionner en tout cas c'est la
direction qu'on prendra notre groupe
nous serons par exemple attentifs à ce
que la perte d'un emploi n'entraîne pas
automatiquement la perte de droit de
séjour sur un autre plan nous veillerons
à ce qu'une attention particulière soit
portée aux territoires ultramarins
concernés par les enjeux migratoires les
fêtes parle d'eux-mêmes ils n'ont que
trop durer pour prendre l'exemple du
site alisté par notre collègue à Mayotte
50% de la population est immigrée mais
24 000 étrangers en situation
irrégulière ont été reconduits à la
frontière l'an passé 78% de plus qu'en
2020 je ne vous parle pas ni de la
Guyane ou de la Réunion ou mes collègues
pourraient en parler bien madame
première ministre pour écouter sur les
sénateurs ultramarins du groupe RDPI
pour co-construire le projet de loi le
futur projet de loi ensuite comment ne
pas évoquer les causes profondes de la
crise migratoire vous l'avez dit madame
la Première ministre la maîtrise des
flux migratoires passe par le
développement les pays d'origine là
encore ne cédons ni aux simplisme ni aux
populismes nous tendons souvent cette
musique insidieuse sur laquelle il
vaudrait mieux allouer l'argent du
contribuable seul priorité national
plutôt que le gaspiller dans une aide
inefficace à des payer à des pays
noyautés par la corruption il n'y a rien
de plus faux et de plus caricatural nous
ne sommes pas dupes les relations entre
migrations et développement sont
complexes c'est pourquoi l'aide publique
au développement n'a jamais été autant
conçu pour être l'alpha et l'oméga de
notre politique migratoire c'est aussi
pourquoi notre aide doit impérativement
s'accompagner d'une sécurisation des
parcours migratoires à savoir permettre
aux migrants d'effectuer des
allers-retours entre la France et leur
pays d'origine sans craindre de basculer
dans la clandestinité une première étape
a été franchie en 2016 avec la création
du passeport talent et c'est un franc
succès c'est pour cela que nous
soutenons l'idée du gouvernement de
simplifier ce titre de séjour pleurer
annuel et de les tendre professions
médicales enfin les gens terminerai par
là
nous avons assurément les visions très
divergentes sur la politique migratoire
mes chers collègues cependant
accorde-nous sur un point la gestion des
flux migratoires relève de la
souveraineté nationale mais nécessite
dans le même temps un minimum de
coopération européenne la présidence
française du Conseil de l'Union
européenne a obtenu cette année ses
avancées essentielles sur le pacte de
l'asile de la migrate du migration les
efforts restent à fournir pour boucler
les dossiers majeurs à commencer par la
réforme du système de Dublin et la
création d'un nouveau mécanisme de
solidarité la France elle est au
rendez-vous la solidarité quand elle se
mobilise aux côtés des Afghans en fuyant
les régimes des talibans des Ukrainiens
fuyant la guerre ou des migrants secouru
en mer il est urgent quel état membres
survontent leur divergence ne pense pas
nous ne pouvons pas faire l'économie
d'un cadre européen commun pour la
gestion de la migration et de l'asile
sans cela l'Europe pourrait ne pas
résister à ce nouveau
accent migratoire et qui est d'ampleur
comparable qui n'a pas comparable depuis
2015 c'est la raison pour laquelle
madame Premier ministre nous écouterons
vos positions nous étudierons votre
texte de loi et nous apporterons notre
soutien sur les bases que vous avez
évoqué et que je viens de rappeler je
vous remercie
la parole
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant au président Pierre
Laurent
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste
la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre messieurs les minis chers
collègues le débat d'aujourd'hui est
censé ouvrir celui que nous aurons début
2023 sur un nouveau texte de loi sur
l'immigration ce sera le 29e en 40 ans
on prélude à ce projet de loi vous avez
publié le 17 novembre une circulaire
mettant gravement en cause le droit
inconditionnel à l'hébergement d'urgence
pour les étrangers les structures
d'accueil et les associations sont vents
debout contre cette circulaire la
discussion commence donc très mal si
elle partait sur de telles bases autour
de textes votre texte de loi pourrait
être un nouvel appel d'air à tous les
débordements tous les fantasmes sur la
subversion migratoire sur les
assimilations immigration délinquance
qui pourrissent le débat public depuis
tant d'années l'hystérie soulevée par
l'arrivée de l'Océane Viking on est le
dernier exemple
pourrions-nous au contraire enfin
débattre sérieusement et sereinement les
migrations sont un enjeu essentiel du
monde et de l'époque actuelle depuis
toujours la France comme d'autres
grandes démocraties s'est construite en
accueillant des migrants pendant
longtemps c'est cela aussi qui a
contribué à faire de la France aux yeux
des peuples du monde la patrie des
droits de l'homme mais rompant avec
cette histoire au fil des lois
régressives nous sommes devenus un des
pays les plus restrictifs d'Europe car
loin des fantasmes c'est cela la réalité
des chiffres nous vivons une grave crise
de l'accueil et un traitement de plus de
plus en plus dégradant des migrants en
France et en Europe un traitement
indigne des droits humains
oui il faut débattre car les causes des
migrations sont multiples guerres
pauvreté extrême violence faites aux
femmes répression des droits humains
catastrophe climatiques jettent des
millions de femmes d'hommes et d'enfants
sur les routes de l'exil la
mondialisation aussi a changé beaucoup
de choses car les habitants de la
planète ou qu'ils vivent considèrent que
les inégalités mondiales et le deux
poids du mesure dans le traitement de la
vie humaine ne sont plus acceptables
agissons-nous contre ces inégalités ces
insécurités mondiales bien au contraire
la politique des pays les plus riches
comme le nôtre ne cessent de les
renforcer citons quelques exemples les
opérations militaires à répétition qui
déstabilise nombre d'États du Sud et du
Proche-Orient les ajustements
structurels et les traités de
libre-échange qui laissent exemples les
services publics de ces pays et
assignent leurs économies à
l'extraversion contre leurs besoins de
développement interne le contrôle
monétaire que nous continuons d'exercer
sur les pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest y Alex
français F1 qui les empêche d'avoir les
moyens d'un financement dans leur
développement les internoiements face à
la crise climatique dont le dont
témoigne l'échec de la COP 27 c'est de
tous là dont nous devrions parler si
nous voulons débats de sérieusement des
migrations mais nous n'allons pas en
parler et certains nous rediront avec
des mots nouveaux la France ne peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde mais
à chaque fois que des solutions
concrètes sont mises sur la table pour
traiter les causes réelles de désordre
mondiaux et des conséquences qu'elles
entraînent toutes ces idées sont
balayées d'un revers de main la rivière
des réfugiés fuyant la guerre en Syrie
aurait pu signer une nouvelle prise de
conscience en Europe Angela Merkel avait
déclaré courageusement en 2016 nous y
arriverons ce fut l'échec et le retour
des murs et des barbelés en 2021 après
la prise de Kaboul par les talibans
Emmanuel Macron ne trouvait plus qu'à
s'inquiéter face aux risques des flux
migrat irrégulier l'Europe a tourné le
dos à ses devoirs d'accueil et de
solidarité humaine la présidente
française de l'UE a passé son tour sur
le pacte d'asile et immigration
aujourd'hui le non-respect des clés de
répartition solidaire à l'échelle
européenne un temps évoqué associé à
l'absurde de règlement Dublin génère
souffrance et indignité sur le continent
nous vivons avec la multiplication des
camps d'exilés des violences
condamnables aux frontières des dizaines
de milliers de morts en Méditerranée
dans la Manche ou sur la route des
Balkans l'Europe n'a plus qu'une
obsession externaliser le traitement des
migrants et marchander avec les pays de
départ les reconduites aux frontières
plutôt que de considérer ces états comme
des partenaires pour la coopération et
le développement ces politiques qui
n'arrêteront rien tant les causes des
migrations sont profondes ne font
contraire que favoriser les compteurs
les contournements et les migrations
irrégulières quand il faudrait au
contraire travailler à des voies légales
et sécurisées de migration
et ces voix légales et sécurisées sont
possibles car sinon comment expliquer
que l'Europe puisse accueillir à juste
titre d'ailleurs plusieurs millions
d'Ukrainiens un Afghan fuyant l'état
Liban une nigériane fuyant un mariage
forcé au l'excision un congolais fuyant
les massacres une famille du Pakistan
fuyant les inondations valent-ils moins
à nos yeux mais de tout cela nous ne
débattrons probablement pas votre projet
pour ce que nous en savons puisque nous
n'avons pas le texte sans vouloir se
concentrer sur deux sujets présentés
comme les deux phases d'une même pièce
la régularisation par le travail pour
les uns l'accélération des expulsions
pour les autres vous nous demandez donc
de nous concentrer sur la situation de
ceux qui sont déjà entrés sur notre sol
donc sur ces deux sujets quelques
remarques sur la question du travail
vous connaissez notre opposition elle
est claire nous sommes pour la
régularisation de tous ceux qui
travaillent les grèves de son papier ont
montré clairement que des filières
entières emploient ces travailleurs sans
les déclarer au vu et au sud tous il ne
mesure que le travail de personnes car
nous peinons aujourd'hui à recruter il
travaille pour notre pays et sont
pourtant maintenus dans une situation de
vulnérailles vulnérabilité insupportable
nous ne voulons pas de quota et nous
serons vigilants sur cette affaire de
liste des métiers en tension le
gouvernement serait prêt donc à
accueillir des étrangers mais à une
condition leur utilité pour nous il ne
doit pas s'agir de régulariser des
pratiques d'exploitation patronales il
doit s'agir de régulariser des femmes et
des hommes qui par leur travail peuvent
enrichir notre pays et sécuriser leur
vie nous sommes favorables à la
suppression du délai de carence afin de
permettre aux demandeurs d'asile de
travailler des les six premiers mois en
France nous plaidons pour les
travailleurs pour une régularisation de
plein droit non soumise à la durée préc
des contrats avec un titre de séjour
d'une durée minimale de deux ans pour
permettre à ses salariés de sécuriser
leur vie et leur installation le
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin
évoque aussi ça a été rappelé ce soir
l'exigence de réussir un test de
français pour l'obtention d'un titre de
séjour pluriannuel évidemment personne
ne peut être contre que les étrangers en
France et qui viennent travailler chez
nous après le français mais nous serons
attentifs là aussi pour que ce ne soit
pas un sujet de discrimination et
d'ailleurs combien de Français aux
origines immigrées ont mis des années
avant de maîtriser notre langue
nationale leur langue d'adoption si au
contraire le titre que vous envisagiez
pour les travailleurs sans papiers ne
courait que pour la stricte durée du
contrat de travail sa fin vaudrait alors
au qtf et expulsion le cycle infernal
serait perpétré nous nous inquiétons
donc de l'abus de vulnérabilité
découlant de la dépendance économique et
administrateur du travailleur à l'égard
de son employeur quand on second volet
le renforcement des auqtf que vous
présentez faussement comme une
contrepartie à l'autre
d'autres sujets le risque est grand de
prendre de plus en plus de largesse avec
le respect du droit vous voulez qu'une
au qtf valent expulsion on peut aisément
supposer qu'une telle décision sera
sévèrement éprouvée par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme car
portant atteinte au droit un recours
effectif garanti par l'article 6 de la
Convention européenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme du point de vue
procédurel vous affirmez la volonté de
généraliser le juge unique à la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile vous risquez
de déshumaniser les procédures
administratives avec un risque de rejet
systématique cette
déshumanisation passera aussi par la
généralisation des audiences en vidéo
que vous envisagez cet éloignement à sa
symbolique car la présence le corps et
ses marques la souffrance ont duré par
l'immigrants n'est pas perceptible de la
même façon dans une procédure menée en
présentiel voilà en quelques mots
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
madame la Première ministre dans quel
état d'esprit et avec quel principe nous
aborderons le débat à venir sur votre
projet de loi je vous remercie si au
président et donner la parole
à collecte mélo notre collègue pour le
groupe Les Indépendants République et
territoires
la parole
monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre mais sur les
ministres mes chers collègues faire une
loi et ne pas la faire exécuter c'est
autoriser la chose qu'on veut défendre
la phrase du cardinal de Richelieu
trouve une résonance particulière dans
l'actualité récente autour d'un sigle
dont aucun Français n'avait entendu
parler il y a quelques mois et que tout
se connaissent aujourd'hui au
qtf depuis des années moins de 20% de
ces décisions sont exécutées il y a dans
d'autres pays des lois qui déterminent
qui peut ou ne peut pas rentrer vivre
sur notre territoire elles ne sont pas
respectées la situation actuelle est
incompréhensible pour les législateurs
que nous sommes pour les Français que
nous représentons et même pour les
étrangers concernés la France est l'une
des premières puissances mondiales elle
doit être en mesure de contrôler ses
frontières depuis longtemps ce n'est
pourtant pas vraiment le cas
cet état de fait ne date pas d'hier les
gouvernements se sont succédés et la
politique migratoire n'a jamais été
jugée satisfaisante dans notre pays ce
n'est pas seulement gênant pour notre
administration c'est dangereux pour nous
institutions en n'étant pas en mesure ou
en ne souhaitant pas donner un cap clair
à cette politique migratoire nous
mettons en danger notre démocratie et la
cohésion de la nation de plus en plus de
peuples européens portent au pouvoir des
populistes et des extrémistes même si ce
n'est pas la seule raison les
considérations migratoires ont joué un
grand rôle dans le choix des
Britanniques de sortir de l'Union
européenne si l'Allemagne connaît une
montée de l'extrême droite la crise
migratoire de 2015 n'y est pas étrangère
c'est un problème que rencontre
également l'Autriche la Suède ou
l'Italie notre pays ne fait pas
exception
d'élection en élections progresse une
extrême droite auparavant très
minoritaire au Parlement aujourd'hui
elle représente le deuxième groupe de
l'Assemblée nationale certains
copiés ces réponses simplissent en
espérant que les Français préféreront la
copie à l'original c'est un pari
hasardeux au succès très peu probable
entre la porte grand ouverte proposée
par une extrême gauche qui refuse de
voir que notre pays comme aucun pays
d'ailleurs n'a pas les moyens ni
économiques ni politique d'accueillir le
monde entier et la fermeture à double
tour réclamer par l'autre côté de
l'hémicycle devenu marchand d'angoisse
nos concitoyens ont le droit de se voir
proposer une alternative crédible
pour cela il faut d'abord dire
clairement que l'immigration ne doit à
aucun prix se faire au détriment de la
cohésion de notre nation
quand la France qu'il revient de décider
d'accueillir ou non des migrants sur son
territoire c'est à nous de fixer les
conditions de cet accueil et nous ne
devons pas accepter que l'immigration
puisse remettre en cause la façon dont
notre société a choisi de vivre dans des
conditions qui doivent rester contrôlées
la France accorde à certains étrangers
l'asile sur son territoire cette
procédure par sa nature mais aussi pour
demeurer soutenables ne peut être
exceptionnelle sans la maîtrise des
frontières qui permet de choisir
d'accueillir au nom des migrants notre
société risque de se déliter il nous
faut tout contraire trouver une formule
qui nous permet de tirer au mieux partie
de l'immigration bon nombre de nos
entreprises font face à une pénurie de
main d'oeuvre
pour poursuivre leur activité pour
conserver leurs compétitivité beaucoup
de nos entrepreneurs recourtent à
l'immigration l'exemple britannique
était différent à cet égard en
choisissant son immigration la France
pourrait sélectionner les compétences
dont elle a besoin cela permettra à
notre économie de maintenir son
dynamisme et de pourvoir aux emplois
pour lesquels une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre est constatée dans l'ensemble
de l'Europe par ailleurs le travail
éloigne de nous trois grands mots
l'ennui le vice et le besoin d'isol
terre le travail constitue un effet l'un
des meilleurs facteurs d'intégration
cependant les capacités professionnelles
seules ne seraient suffire il faut
établir clairement les termes du contrat
pour entrer dans votre société les
immigrants doivent un accepter les
règles en partager des valeurs et un
embrasser la culture ce sont eux qui
souhaitent nous rejoindre et il demeure
libre de choisir où ils veulent aller il
ne s'agit pas là seulement de protéger
notre mode de vie ces conditions sont
également nécessaires à l'intégration
des immigrés par notre société et leur
permettront de devenir ainsi des
citoyens à part entière pour que cela
fonctionne nous devons veiller à ce que
celles et ceux qui seront entrés en
France en respectant ses engagements ne
fasse l'objet d'aucune discrimination si
tous ces prérequis ne sont pas
satisfaits nous concitoyens continuerons
d'avoir le sentiment de subir
l'immigration et les immigrer ne
parviendront pas à se fondre au sein de
notre société je l'ai déjà dit la
problématique migratoire ne concerne pas
seulement la France
l'Europe dans son entier par son respect
des libertés sont dynamisme économique
ces figures d'Eldorado pour beaucoup de
personnes dans le monde dans tous les
pays de l'Union la population vieillit
la main d'oeuvre se raréfie et dans le
même temps la dépendance de nos aînés
s'accroît de nombreux États membres font
face au même défi il nous faut donc
trouver ensemble des solutions qui
protègent notre mode de vie à la fois
contre ses propres limites mais aussi
contre les ingérences étrangères à la
suite des chantages Turcs l'Union
européenne a pris conscience de
l'impossibilité de continuer à
sous-traiter un pays tiers la gestion de
ses frontières extérieures les Européens
doivent assumer leur responsabilité la
montée en puissance des moyens de
l'agence Frontex doit à cet égard être
salué au début de l'année prochaine le
gouvernement présentera un nouveau texte
sur l'immigration vous avez dit Monsieur
le Ministre vouloir être méchant avec
les méchants et gentil avec avec les
gentil en d'autres termes vous nous
proposez de choisir un peu mieux qui
doit venir ou rester dans notre pays et
qui ne le doit pas nous y sommes
favorables nous
ne fait comme tant d'autres que
l'immigration peut constituer une menace
pour notre société si elle est
incontrôlée cela ne nous empêche pas
d'être pleinement conscient qu'elle est
à bien des égards nécessaires
regardons la réalité en face nous notons
bien la nécessité de faire évoluer une
législation qui part manque
d'application a perdu beaucoup de sens
nous vous soutiendrons donc dans votre
démarche avec une extrême droite en
progression croissante et une extrême
gauche chaque jour plus irresponsable
nous sommes tous ensemble contraints de
réussir là où nos prédécesseurs échouent
depuis 40 ans je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Colin je vais donner
maintenant la parole de notre collègue
Maryse Carrère pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues il y a quelques semaines
nous avons pu amorcer cette discussion à
l'occasion de l'examen des crédits de la
mission asile et immigration et la
position du groupe RDSE n'a pas changé
depuis la question de la politique
d'immigration de notre pays compte parmi
les plus difficiles elle est sujette au
fantasmes et aux peurs parfois
irrationnelles à la charge d'une
république modérée d'éviter les écueils
populistes pour aboutir à une solution
équilibrée seulement il existe une autre
dérive qui doit attirer la vigilance du
législateur et donc aussi du
gouvernement celle de faire une loi
juste pour dire qu'on a légiféré je sais
Monsieur le Ministre que vous portez de
vrais ambitions je ne les partage pas
toutes c'est le jeu de la démocratie
seulement le Parlement a déjà adopté en
septembre 2018 la loi portée par Gérard
Collomb pour une immigration maîtrisée
un droit d'asile effectif et une
intégration réussie c'était il y a 4 ans
autrement dit il pas si longtemps
quel est le bilan des mesures de ce
texte c'est qu'en est-il des garanties
d'exercices et des factivités du droit
d'asile qu'il devait mettre en place
presque 10 articles étaient consacrés au
renforcement de l'efficacité et de la
crédibilité de la lutte contre les
migrations irrégulières qu'en est-il ici
aussi qu'en est-il en particulier de la
mise en oeuvre des mesures d'éloignement
et de modifications qui avaient été
faites en matière de rétention
administrative et je pense en
particulier à l'allongement à 90 jours
de la durée de la rétention
administrative avant de légiférer à
nouveau il serait légitime que nous
puissions analyser la disposition
réduisant de 120 à 90 jours le délai
pour déposer une demande d'asile à
l'échelle de nos départements le constat
n'est pas un ami amélioration de
l'accueil ni du traitement des dossiers
cette mesure était pourtant destinée à
réduire les délais de réponse aux
situations difficiles
puisque nous devrions bientôt légiférer
cet état des lieux nous permettrait de
savoir où et comment agir efficacement
alors deux aspects principaux
occupent la question de l'immigration
ces derniers mois l'effectivité des
auqtf et la place des travailleurs
irréguliers j'espère néanmoins que
d'autres sujets ne seront pas écartés
par exemple l'amélioration de
l'accompagnement des personnes
étrangères les plus vulnérables celles
victimes de violence ou bien émises
isolée l'accompagnement des familles
également question chère au groupe RDSE
nous allons beaucoup parler des occitf
c'est normal c'est normal car il y a
manifestement un problème avec ce
dispositif si je maintiens à certains
chiffres la France délivre en moyenne
120 000 au qtf par an mais moins de 10%
sont exécutés les 40 C2 chiffres
montrent bien l'absurdité de ce rouage
administratif particulièrement pesant
tant pour notre nation que pour ceux qui
sont l'objet de ces décisions quasi
aléatoires
tout cela justifie qu'il faille repenser
les différents mécanismes qui entourent
les OQTF afin d'en permettre une
meilleure application c'est à dire plus
efficace et plus humaine
derrière cette idée nous défendrons
l'idée d'une simplification du
contentieux des étrangers à condition
qu'elle regarde en tissent un droit
effectif à contester les décisions de
l'administration en plus d'assurer un
meilleur traitement des recours et la
bonne administration de la justice nous
regarderons bien sûr avec vigilance ces
mesures pourquoi pas généraliser les
audiences à proximité des centres de
rétention administrative ou par moyen
audiovisuel pour éviter les déplacements
des retenus pourquoi pas aussi créer des
pôles territoriaux labellisés pour la
gestion du droit d'asile mais il ne faut
pas que ces dispositifs soient des
contraintes pour les personnes migrantes
et viennent mettre en difficulté le
respect de leurs droits ensuite nous
entendons qu'il faille trouver le moyen
de désengorger les préfectures en effet
il est constaté que dans de très
nombreux cas les décisions préfectorales
sont simples à annuler devant le juge en
raison de mauvaises appréciations par
l'administration conduisant à de
mauvaises décision toutefois ce
désengorgement ne pourra consister qu'à
délivrer moins d'eau qtf pour que
chacune soit mieux instruite et ainsi
juridiquement fondée la politique du
chiffre consistant à prononcer
massivement des auditefs se révélant
inefficaces en pratique
d'une autre manière à la surpopulation
des centres de rétention administratives
montrent également
l'inefficacité de notre politique de
contrôle de l'immigration puisqu'elle ne
permet pas de répondre aux flux qui est
imposé j'espère que nous serons en
mesure d'y apporter des solutions
concrètes et en ce sens dans les aspects
utiles il a été annoncé la possibilité
de mettre en place un titre de séjour
métier en tension notre groupe n'a pas
d'a priori de principe sur une telle
mesure bien au contraire chacun sait
qu'actuellement une part importante de
l'immigration irrégulière travaillent
sans être déclaré ce travail illégal
permet d'offrir de la main d'oeuvre dans
des secteurs de métiers
je pourrais citer de nombreux exemples
certains ont la chance d'être mise en
lumière un artisan boulanger pour lequel
un village se mobilise ailleurs un
apprenti bouché cela ont de la chance
mais il y en a des milliers d'autres qui
travaillent par exemple sur les marchés
dans la restauration ou les métiers du
bâtiment tout ce travail pour notre pays
leur métier sont souvent essentiels au
quotidien de nos concitoyens
pour autant ils sont dans une situation
irrégulière cette configuration place
ses travailleurs et les employeurs dans
une précarité difficile à admettre un
point stable faible rémunération absence
de tout dispositif de sécurité sociale
alors pourquoi pas un titre de séjour
spécial comme vous pourriez le proposer
monsieur le ministre mais à la seule
condition qu'il puisse être effectif et
dans le respect du droit du travail sans
aucune dérogation
autrement dit d'une part nous
n'admetrons pas qu'il soit question
d'offrir aux entreprises une menzoeuvre
à bas coût pour certains métiers boudés
par les résidents nationaux et d'autre
part il faudra impérativement
accompagner le dispositif par des
mécanismes de contrôle et des sanctions
pour les entreprises qui continueraient
de recourir au travail non déclaré bref
vous l'aurez compris ce projet de loi
annoncé suscite de la part des élus du
groupe RDSE des attentes importantes et
nous resterons pleinement mobilisés pour
vous accompagner dans l'examen de ce
texte je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
solidarité et territoire
paroles
merci monsieur le Président
alors la première ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres chers
de l'étude du 29e texte depuis 1980 sur
ce sujet la France ne peut pas
accueillir tout le monde si elle veut
accueillir bien voilà ce que déclarait
le président en 2019 pourtant rien dans
les derniers budgets présentés ou des
dernières politiques annoncées nées le
reflet de cette doctrine si mieux
accueillir ces procédés dans le budget
2023 une baisse des crédits octroyés
pour la location des demandeurs d'asile
de plus d'un tiers la discussion risque
d'être compliquée dans le décalage entre
les actes et la parole est grand je
crois au vrai en même temps sur la
politique migratoire aussi disait-il
toujours dans ce même entretien
ce que nous voyons ne me semble être que
la jambe droite de cette politique
migratoire peut-être parce que c'est
celle qui porte réellement ses
convictions comment sinon justifier le
prise ultra présent de l'aspect sécurité
comment comprendre qu'un sujet de
société importante puisse être considéré
comme réellement prise en charge qu'au
travers d'une vision sécuritaire
peut-être aurions-nous aimé voir et nous
pencher sur la création d'un véritable
ministère dédié à la politique de
l'immigration de l'accueil et de
l'intégration
sans regarder ces débats sous l'aspect
humanitaire de fraternité de solidarité
et même de réalisme ou de pragmatisme
économique social et climatique non je
le redis les questions d'immigration ne
peuvent pas se limiter ni même saborder
prioritairement via leur HP sécurité le
débat d'aujourd'hui devrait je l'espère
permettre de recentrer l'immigration un
phénomène normal historique récurrent
qui a participé et participera à la
construction de notre pays un phénomène
démographique complexe tributaire des
guerres des famines conséquences mettant
du changement climatique un phénomène
qui conduira encore plus de mouvements
dans les années à venir entre les
continents et au sein même de l'Europe
en 2017
le candidat Prométhée nous examinerons
les demandes d'asile en moins de 6 mois
recours compris c'est nécessaire pour
accueillir dignement les réfugiés qui
ont droit à la protection de la France
pourtant pour les juridictions
administratives et pour la CNDA les
Costa Sur les mêmes une embolisation
totale d'un système mal calibré de
l'accès aux préfectures et à l'OFI pour
l'obtention de s'impro nouvellement de
titre de séjour en passant par l'accès
au travail jusqu'à une prise en charge
médicale effective les parcours des
migrants sont trop souvent semés
d'embûches tout le contraire de
profiteur du système maintenant des
milliers de personnes dans la précarité
et que dire de l'ambition portée de
supprimer les protections contre
l'éloignement pour motif d'ordre public
par exemple pour les étrangers résidant
en France depuis plus de 10 ans nous
groupe écologie solidarité et
territoires absorbe clairement en faveur
d'une meilleure célérité des procédures
mais jamais au départ des droits des
personnes jamais au dépôt des conditions
de travail des agents de votre service
public jugé plus vite mais surtout jugez
mieux vous avancez comme objectif
l'application de 100% des au qtf
quelle est cet affichage politique quel
est le chemin pour y arriver quels sont
les dispositifs concrets mis en place le
taux n'a été que de 20% de manière assez
constante ces dernières décennies nous
pensons entre autres que la
multiplication des trains pour répondre
aux difficultés diplomatiques des
éloignements est un non sens et que dire
des principes placements ancra pour des
occultés à vieilles de trois ans sans
évaluation de leur situation personnelle
ou professionnelle il est clair que cela
s'accorde bien avec la volonté affichée
du ministère de l'Intérieur envers ses
étrangers de leur rendre la vie
impossible je poste aujourd'hui à
l'enterrement définitif de la promesse
d'Orléans de 2017 qui avait vu le
président déclaré qu'aucun des vendeur
d'asile de dormir et dehors rien de ce
qui nous a été présenté ne s’appelle
pourtant à ce sujet essentiel à Calais
97% des expulsions des lieux de vie ne
sont pas suivis de mise à l'abri c'est
d'autant plus inacceptables que les
pèles ont couru pour avoir facilité
l'entrée la circulation le séjour
irrégulier d'étrangers sera augmenté
nous inquiétudes sans à ce sujet pour
les volontaires bénévoles des
associations
en 2022 le président candidat voulait
poursuivre la refonte de l'organisation
de l'asile et du droit au séjour pour
décider beaucoup plus rapidement qui est
éligibles la crise du crédit a montré
que l'Europe que notre pays pouvait
accueillir bien accueillir rapidement
accueillir lorsque la volonté politique
qui est le dérogatoire
ukrainien qui a fait ses preuves de
devrait-il attendre à devenir la règle
aller plus vite c'est permettre un
système de rendez-vous plus efficace en
préfecture souvent début du succession
d'obstacles tel un mur administratif
j'étais déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
les agents sur le terrain ou qu'ils se
trouvent se retrouvent en difficulté
face à une perte de sens de leur mission
et des moyens qui leur sont accordés
cela débouche aussi sur une insécurité
des personnes sans droit sur votre
territoire qui devient de la proie des
réseaux privés de titres de séjour les
étrangers sont maintenus dans la
dépendance d'un accompagnement assuré
par les associations ils ne peuvent pas
obtenir de travailler déclaré de
logement ou au bon accès aux soins nous
accueillons plutôt favorablement les
prévises de la régularisation avancée
des travailleurs exerçants sur notre sol
ou la volonté nouvelle de ne plus
détourner le regard face aux employeurs
peu scrupuleux rien n'est cependant
évoqué pour le parcours vers la
nationalité française
certains de ces travailleurs intégrés
souvent dans des métiers de Première
League pendant la crise du covid en
bénéficiait de ce parcours de
reconnaissance vers la nationalité
pourtant rien dans le débat actuel ne
permet de reformer cette accès à la
nationalité pour ces personnes intégrées
qui le souhaitent pour le reste nous
sommes pour le mois circonspect sur la
notion de travailleurs des métiers en
tension sur notre sol une sorte de
version de la notion de travailleur
méritants que vous nous présentez
derrière ces annonces il y a un vrai
sujet l'utilité sociale de l'immigré
est-elle une assignation à résidence
comme le disait le président
imaginons une personne accueillie sur
votre territoire car travailleur dans un
secteur en tension ce secteur est
attention pour des raisons bien
particulières difficultés de conditions
de travail précarité de l'emploi salaire
est suffisant ces travailleurs sera-t-il
condamné à rester dans ce secteur pour
rester en France pire en cas de perte
d'emploi
bénéficiera-t-il toujours d'un titre de
séjour cette vision qui pourrait devenir
utilitariste très rapidement du
travailleur étranger interchangeable
nous est particulièrement problématique
le gouvernement aussi présenté un désir
de renforcer les exigences sur la
maîtrise du français certes c'est normal
mais avec quel modalités
d'accompagnement qui seront les
évaluateurs qui seront les formateurs la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
et la priorité du gouvernement l'axe
presque pudique de réflexion de sa
politique migratoire d'entacle la
position de notre groupe est connue de
tous nous passons au contraire que la
question migratoire ne doit pas ne peut
pas se limiter aux prises du travail ou
de la sécurité les moyens de
l'administration doivent d'abord être
tournés vers la facilitation de l'accès
au séjour et de l'intégration
la crédibilisation outrancière de
l'étranger et contraire à nos valeurs la
modification des procédures judiciaires
administratives sous couvert de
simplification quitte à s'éloigner du
contradictoire ou de la collégialité et
d'autres principes des droits de la
défense n'est pas acceptable et là
backnot list comment ne pas aborder
votre silence assourdissant sur la
problématique des frontières y compris
au sein de l'Union européenne surveillez
plus que secourir nous l'avons bien vu
avec le président Gothard et d'autres de
mes collègues j'ai bien vu la situation
à Montgenèvre par exemple au-delà de ne
pas se courir beaucoup d'associations
rapportent encore aujourd'hui le manque
d'enregistrement des demande d'asile
malgré les rappels répétés du Conseil
d'État sur la réalité de ce droit ou est
la réflexion à ce sujet et l'ambition du
gouvernement sur ces refoulements sur
vas-y les gaufresières notre pays
s'odore essaie d'orgueillir d'accueillir
et de sauver nous devons veiller à une
école dossier à une inconditionnalité de
la dignité dans l'accueil à juste titre
car c'est vraiment notre odeur je
regrette que cette odeur cette variable
entre l'Aquarius et l'océan viking
l'acceptabilité des refus doit centrer
dans le respect des procédures et des
personnes chers collègues n'y voyait ni
naïveté ni idéalise plutôt pique mais au
contraire entendait le besoin de bien
accueillir de mieux respecter les
devoirs des personnes arrivant sur notre
sol et notre ambition de travail au
niveau européen
la parole de notre collègue Esther
Benbassa pour la Réunion administrative
des sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe
la parole
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
coincé entre une extrême droite
obnubilée par le grand remplacement et
une droite en crise monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur et ses amis sont prêts à
occulter les vrais problèmes du pays à
flatter les bases instants encourager le
rejet et la suspicion
notre ministre en orgueille deux fois la
ville aux exilés que l'Allemagne et nous
promet que tout rejet d'asile vaudra
obligation de quitter le territoire donc
encore plus de cutter et combien d'entre
elles seront-elles exécutées vous savez
que vous n'aurez jamais les moyens de
vos ambitions
cette loi est la 30e
depuis 80 les gouvernements se
sucent la rengaine ne change pas
l'immigration coûterait un pognon de
dingue et les exilés traverseraient les
mers au périls de leur vie que pour
bénéficier de tous les avantages sociaux
tel l'aide médicale de l'état l'idée est
d'ailleurs partagée par la droite
sénatoriale qui a déjà exprimé le
souhait dans un bel esprit d'humanité de
réduire de 350 millions le budget de
l'Ame dans le PLF 2023
l'étranger à la peau sombre est un
profiteur et un futur délinquant
responsable de tous les mots de la
France
même sous un pont sous une tente
d'infortune même privé d'une couverture
pour passer l'hiver face à lui le bon
réfugié l'Ukrainien par exemple est reçu
dignement et tant mieux parce que à la
peau claire et chrétien on aura
désormais le migrant économiquement
utile à qui
uniquement un titre un titre de séjour
temporaire métier de intention pour le
lui retirer une fois l'attention passée
votre politique d'accueil n'est que
sinistre le plâtre visant juste à rendre
acceptable ces milliers d'immigrés
destinés à régler notre crise du
recrutement l'État abandonne à leur sort
les étrangers sur son territoire
la situation décras et catastrophique la
situation des mineurs non accompagnée
aussi la france terre d'accueil
un mythe désormais
messieurs les ministres avec cette
politique à temps prévenir les esprits
contre les étrangers et le danger qu'il
représente dans 10 ans y aurait-il
encore une place dans ce pays pour des
Dupont-Moretti ou même pour des Darmanin
j'en doute quel dommage n'est-ce pas
messieurs les ministres
merci
la parole
on va maintenant être ministre monsieur
Olivier bèche ministre délégué en charge
du commerce extérieur de l'attractivité
des Français de l'étranger
monsieur le ministre de la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à l'issue de ce débat
permettez-moi de vous donner quelques
éléments concernant l'expélier à notre
politique étrangère qui ont été abordés
dans ce débat la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères qui m'a demandé
de la représenter aujourd'hui la
rappeler la semaine dernière devant
l'Assemblée nationale la question
migratoire est aujourd'hui à l'élément
central dans la conduite de notre
politique étrangère à cet égard trois
principes nous guides en matière
migratoire
attractivité et organisation des
mobilités légales solidarité avec les
plus vulnérables et fermeté face au
fusil régulier
la France souhaite porter une vision
équilibrée dans le champ migratoire
d'abord nous sommes attachés au
développement d'une migration légale
bénéfique à notre groupe et nous
veillons tout particulièrement au
renforcement de notre activité à l'égard
des étudiants et des talents nous avons
cette année atteint le chiffre record de
400 000 inscriptions d'étudiants
étrangers en France et la délivrance de
12000 visas dans le cadre des passeports
talents permettez-moi de vous dire
également que notre politique de visa
n'est en rien arbitraire comme j'ai pu
l'entendre elle poursuit en revanche un
objectif d'être activité au service de
l'influence de notre pays
nous portons également avec force et
Constance la défense du droit
international et nous nous honorons
particulièrement d'être dans le monde
l'un des pays les plus engagés en
matière d'asile nous sommes attachés à
la protection des migrants au respect de
leurs droits fondamentaux et comparé non
l'année prochaine à la demande du
Haut-Commissariat au réfugiés le Forum
mondial des réfugiés c'est le même souci
de la protection des migrants nous a
conduit à lutter avec force contre les
trafics et la traite des êtres humains
en effet et c'est la contrepartie
naturelle de l'ouverture et de la
générosité de notre pays nous sommes
intransigeants sur le respect de nos
lois et de nos valeurs et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes engagés
à lutter avec la même force contre
l'immigration irrégulière pour le retour
la réadmission et la réintégration dans
leur pays d'origine des migrants
irréguliers la France sur la question de
grattoir comme sur bien d'autres
questions recherche donc l'équilibre
nous poursuivons objectif avec nos
partenaires africains la stratégie
migration et développement de la France
couvre plus de 55 pays majoritairement
africains en 2021 les projets engagés
par la France sont élevés à plus de 1,5
milliards d'euros sur la base de
financement conjoint de la France avec
d'autres partenaires principalement
européens nous portons également cette
vision équilibrée dans le cadre européen
et multilatéral si dans cet esprit que
la ministre de l'Europe et les affaires
étrangères a participé hier à Bruxelles
au lancement de deux initiatives dites
équipe Europe consacrée à deux routes
migratoires celle de la Méditerranée
centrale et celle de la Méditerranée
occidentale initié par la France
l'Espagne et l'Italie s'initiative
associe les moyens des institutions
européennes et des États membres pour
chacune de ces routes migratoires c'est
environ un milliard d'euros qui a été
investi avec la mise en place
d'instruments qui doivent permettre de
resserrer une coopération
gros africaine global dans la lutte
contre les filières d'immigration
irrégulière dans l'organisation des
retours mais aussi sur les causes
profondes des migrations irrégulières la
protection des migrants ou encore la
migration légale la France a soutenu
fortement l'objectif européen de
consacrer 10% des moyens d'intervention
extérieurs de l'Union pour des projets
liés aux migrations et cela représente
en tout 10 milliards d'euros sur la
période 2021 2027 nous avons donc un
intérêt à nous inscrire dans cette
logique coopérative indispensable à une
meilleure maîtrise des flux migratoires
nous devons construire ensemble des
partenariats mutuellement bénéfiques
pour nous-mêmes comme pour les pays
d'origine c'est la raison pour laquelle
la France a aussi pris la présidence du
Forum mondial sur la migration et le
développement dont le sommet se tiendra
à Paris début 2024 enfin nous
réfléchirons ensemble en particulier à
l'impact du changement climatique sur la
mobilité humaine dans une approche
transversale et inclusive à des fins du
dialogue et d'anticipation dans un
esprit à la fois de solidarité et de
responsabilité c'est bien cette
équilibre dans la politique migratoire
que nous recherchons également à travers
notre politique étrangère je vous
remercie
notre parole est à monsieur le ministre
du Travail de plein emploi de
l'insertion
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre simplement un mot pour
revenir sur le projet de création d'un
titre de séjour spécifique pour les
métiers en tension puisque monsieur le
sénateur buffet il a évoqué notamment
l'objectif que nous avons avec la
création d'un titre de séjour par la loi
et justement de pouvoir au Parlement
avoir un débat sur les critères d'accès
à ce type de séjour lorsqu'on pense à
une admission exceptionnelle au titre de
la procédure dite valse la circulaire
d'ibals pardonnez-moi il y a des
conditions de présence minimale sur le
territoire d'ancienneté sur le
territoire régulière ou irrégulière des
conditions aussi d'ancienneté dans
l'emploi exercé mais il y a
l'accompagnement obligatoire de chef
d'entreprise qui s'exposent au risque
d'une paiement d'une contribution à
l'OFI avec le titre que nous proposons
le salarié pourra demander sa
régularisation en pouvant prouver
l'ancienneté de son emploi il nous reste
à définir quel est le bon critère
d'ancienneté tout comme l'ancienneté sa
présence sur le territoire
des critères ainsi définit par la loi
seront le principal outil de contrôle de
cette de cette de ce nouveau titre pour
éviter est-ce que vous avez dit craindre
c'est-à-dire un outil de régularisation
massive ça ne sera pas la régularisation
massive et les critères permettront de
nous en prévenir ce titre sera un titre
d'un nom renouvelable et le titre n'est
pas attaché à un emploi ça fait quoi un
certain nombre de d'interrogations mais
bien l'exercice d'un emploi dans un
secteur en tension la liste des métiers
en tension comptant plusieurs dizaines
de métiers ce qui permet à une personne
qui aurait régularisé sa situation par
un tel titre et qui perdrait
éventuellement son emploi de retrouver
un emploi dans un des secteurs en
tension ou de trouver un emploi dans un
autre secteur et dans ce cas-là
sollicité la délivrance d'un titre de
séjour pour motif économique pour motif
salarié en répondant aux règles fixées
par la loi qui existe et que nous
connaissons je ne partage pas totalement
par contre l'inquiétude ou l'objectif du
sénateur bonne Carrère concernant la
rémunération nous vous avez évoqué
monsieur ordinateur l'idée de réserver
ce titre à des salariés qui seraient
recrutés avec un niveau de rémunération
au moins supérieur à la moyenne de la
branche dans laquelle il exerce j'ai
deux difficultés la première c'est que
nous parlons là de régularisation de
salariés qui sont présents sur le
territoire et salarié depuis plusieurs
mois au mois et donc avec un niveau de
salaire qui est danger déjà arrêté et
par ailleurs nous savons aussi l'extrême
hétérogénéité des situations concernées
je pense par ailleurs et je crois que
nous pouvons nous retrouver sur ce point
qu'il faut veiller à ce que ce soit pas
une trappe à bas salaire et que très
très certainement le maintien dans
l'illégalité agit comme une trappe à bas
salaire en maintenant une situation de
dépendance du salarié vis-à-vis de
l'employeur qui plus est quand celui-ci
peut s'avérer un délicat mais je pense
que nous aurons l'occasion dans d'en
discuter et de débattre de tout cela et
enfin en écho l'intervention de madame
la sénatrice Carrère il n'y a pas de
volonté là aussi de favoriser des
situations de précarité
de moindre coût pour l'employeur puisque
dès lors qu'il y aurait régularisation
dès lors qu'il y aurait volonté
d'inscrire la présence du salarié dans
le temps c'est-à-dire avec une carte de
séjour cuir annuelle il y aurait cette
obligation pour les employeurs de
participer à la formation ce qui
implique évidemment qu'il puisse soit
libérer du temps soit participé sur son
plan de formation à cette formation à
l'apprentissage du français et donc nous
cherchons le bon équilibre pour que ce
soit un titre qui sécurise la situation
des employeurs je n'oublie pas que bien
souvent la situation est créée par le
fait que le contrat était signé avec un
salarié en situation régulière qui n'a
pas eu le renouvellement de son titre et
l’employeur ne laissait pas
nécessairement et sécuriser le
travailleur avec cette volonté de sortir
celles et ceux qui connaissent les
situations d'exploitation les plus
dramatiques de cette situation de
dépendance
merci monsieur le ministre
le ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
la parole
merci monsieur le Président peut-être
répondu aux différents orateurs sur la
partie qui me concentre plus directement
après les explications de monsieur le
ministre du Travail peut-être à monsieur
le Président buffet
vous avez fait de nombreuses
propositions monsieur le Président
certaines de recoupent celles que nous
proposons dans le texte de loi que nous
allons présenter après ces débats au
Conseil d'État je dis au sénateur
Laurent la prairie sera souhaité que
nous attendions la fin des concertations
politiques je crois que nous voyons nous
sommes vus pardon et nous voyons très
prochainement le groupe d'ailleurs
communiste la semaine nationale mais
également les débats 51 avant de
transmettre le texte au Conseil d'État
puis enfin de le présenter en conseil
des ministres et donc au Parlement nous
avons donc un certain nombre de d'avis
convergent
des sujets aussi que nous n'avons pas
repris dans le texte après l'arbitrage
du président de la République et de la
prairie je pense à la question autour de
l'aide médicale d'État ou des étrangers
malades parce que nous considérons qu'il
s'agit là de disposition que chaque
année vous étudiez dans le cadre du PDF
et du PLFSS vous le savez plus personne
juste dire peut-être que sur le titre
étranger malade si la question
évidemment se pose et si je ne retiens
rien au fait que seule la France le
porte dans ces conditions des chiffres
qui ont été évoqués la tribune n'ont pas
par vous mais par différents orateurs ne
sont pas tout à fait juste ils le permet
puisque nous avons fait une réforme du
titre étranger malade notamment dans la
loi que l'on puisse ensuite dans des
dispositions portées par le PLFSS et le
PLF et s'il y avait bien effectivement
5000 titres qui étaient
étranger malade en 2019
6850 d'ailleurs en 2016 il y en a plus
que 3700 c'est-à-dire une baisse de 45%
par rapport à l'arrivée du président de
la République en 2017 et de 25% par
rapport aux années près covid donc il y
a plus que 37 centimes d'étrangers
malades essentiellement des 3GS malades
aérotiques des personnes qui sont
atteintes du VIH dans des pays qui ne
connaissent pas notamment les thérapies
sur ce sur ce sujet et je veux dire que
ce que nous avons mis en place et vous
le savez monsieur le Président
c'est-à-dire que lorsque nous expulsions
un étranger notamment un étranger
délinquant
de rétention administratif et qui au
titre de sa maladie parce qu'il peut
avoir une maladie souhaite faire un
appel au titre étranger malade
humanitaire on va dire cela comme ça
désormais un médecin de Luffy
parfaitement indépendant vient constater
évidemment la véracité de la pathologie
et constater si dans le pays d'origine
il a bien la la thérapie pour le faire
et nous le faisons il y a des pays pour
lequel il n'y a pas de thérapie donc
nous gardons ces personnes conformément
à l'engagement de la France mais dans de
très nombreux cas et de très nombreux
cas notamment de pays d'Afrique il y a
c'est c'est thérapies nous expulsions
quand même la personne donc même si le
titre en soit peut-être évidemment
interrogé comme tous les titres de
séjour dans le cadre de ce projet de loi
voilà je pense pas que ce soit
effectivement le débat le même débat
qu'il y a et qui a 5 ans je reviens pas
sur la question de de l'ame et eu un
échange de différence de vie entre les
des sénateurs et il ne sera pas dans le
dans le projet de loi comme je
l'évoquais puisqu'il est dans les textes
financiers peut-être également sur les
exécutions des mesures de d'éloignement
alors c'est sûr que le débat autour des
auqtf devient un peu totémique je dirais
un peu un peu slogan et ne correspond
malheureusement pas tout à fait à la
réalité des choses ce que compte le
ministère de l'Intérieur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et d'ailleurs ce
que vous avez mis dans votre rapport me
semble-t-il en 2019 et 2020 c'est le
nombre de mesures qui à la connaissance
du ministère de l'Intérieur ont été
exécutés
c'est pas la même chose comme de mesure
qui ont été exécutées je m'explique ce
que nous connaissons nous c'est les
personnes qui ont quitté le territoire
Schengen il est très important de
considérer que ces territoires Schengen
puisque quand quelqu'un va de France en
Belgique alors qu'il a le qtf nous ne
savons pas je prends l'exemple de la
ville de Tourcoing il y a 17 points de
passage avec la Belgique il y a pas de
contrôle frontières en Belgique donc
quand les gens qui doivent quitter
territoire national vont dans un état
Schengen qui n'est pas contrôlé aux
frontières nous ne savons pas lorsque
ces personnes sont partis alors c'est
vrai on y reviendra que le système
entrée sortie Schengen puis Ethias nous
permettra de le savoir demain mais
aujourd'hui nous ne savons pas et
deuxième sujet nous ne comptons que ceux
qui ont soit à départ aider passer par
l'OFI soit une exécution de le qtf passé
par la police aux frontières du fait de
son éloignement effectif parce qu'il y a
eu à laisser passer consulaire ou parce
qu'il y a un passeport qui permet aux
policiers frontières de mettre dans un
avion et de raccompagner dans son pays
il y a des tas de gens qui respectent
les règles de la République et quand il
voit qu'ils ne sont pas bienvenue sur de
la République alors qu'ils ont en occupé
F moi des parts aider ou au départ sur
lequel ils ont fait un salon de recours
sont partis du territoire national sans
jamais passer par la préfecture et par
la police aux frontières et c'est
d'ailleurs non madame c'est tout à fait
vrai c'est pour ça que la circulaire que
j'ai prise à la lueur de défaire faits
divers sur quel je reviendrai pas permet
justement de rentrer le nombre de
personnes dans les personnes recherchées
pour justement que passer à la position
frontière nous connaissons exactement de
personnes qui sont parties deuxièmement
le nombre de qtf que vous citer que nous
citons tous que vous citez plus
particulièrement je parle des 121000 qui
ont été répétés ici-bas 2021 ce ne sont
pas le nom de mesure individuelles qui
sont prises ce sont nos mesures tout
court il y a des personnes qui ont
plusieurs mesures individuelles sur
elles peuvent déjà on peut avoir
plusieurs au qtf voir des qtf et une
interdiction de retour sur le territoire
national tout ça ça engendre les 121
mesures mais quand on compare le nombre
de personnes que nous avons envoyé dans
les pays étrangers et le mesure qu'on a
prises évidemment qu'on peut pas tomber
à 100% puisque par nature il y a des
personnes qui ont plusieurs mesures et
c'est parfois jusqu'à 20% des personnes
qui sont dans les fichiers dites des
mesures administratives et puis moi je
voudrais vous citer les chiffres puisque
on les cite tous et effectivement ça a
été rapide personne n'avait dépassé 20
%. je dirais même que l'année 2011-2012
que vous avez pris monsieur le Président
sont n'étaient pas des mauvaises années
à peu près 85 000 mesures prises à cette
époque il y avait je compte en 2011
7970 reconduites et en 2012
6204 conduites si je prends l'exemple de
l'année 2021 il y a eu 124
000 mesures tout confondues c'est-à-dire
y compris des gens qui ont plusieurs
mesures mais on imaginant que ce soit le
chiffre sur lequel on nous correspondons
tous c'est 16984 reconduites c'est à
dire que nous faisons le plus que le
double des reconduites alors qu'il y a
eu moins de doubler de mesure prises
donc on a eu à peu près le même taux
d'exécution monsieur le Président vous
et nous c'est ce que vous avez dit
monsieur le Président le Patriat c'est
vrai que sous le quin du président
Hollande ça s'est beaucoup détérioré si
je prends oui si je prends l'exemple
madame la Gontrie si vous me le
permettez ne vous inquiétez pas je vais
vous répondre monsieur sénateur ne
pressez pas la réponse je suis pas sûr
qu'elle va vous plaire
122000 je prends je prends l'exemple des
mesures que qui ont été prises par le
Hollande on était à peu près une cent
mille mesures prises pour 7000 reconnus
aux frontières on va bien que là ça
c'est effectivement beaucoup détérioré
mais je voudrais dire que la meilleure
année de reconduite à la frontière
malgré les difficultés que nous avons
connues en Syrie parce que je ferai pas
la France de dire que le quinquennat du
président Sarkozy n'avait pas connu les
difficultés que nous connaissons
totalement en Libye en Syrie on
Afghanistan au Soudan qui a multiplié
évidemment les fonds de difficulté
diplomatique et c'est juste pour
expliquer le contexte malgré les
difficultés diplomatiques et des pays en
guerre que nous connaissons depuis le
début du quinquennat du président
Macron je constate que c'est 2019 quelle
année donc precovide de meilleure
additions frontières est-ce que c'est
suffisant la réponse est non parce que
quoi qu'il arrive même 20% ça reste un
cinquième seulement une surprise et donc
effectivement nous devons réinterroger
profondément c'est ce que nous avons dit
le système des reconduites aux
frontières et des auqtf et du placement
ce monsieur bonne Carrère vous évoquez
l'entrée sortie Schengen justement qu'il
faut mettre en place et Monsieur Lecomte
évoqué Ethias la France est prête la
France est prête l'affaire l'entrée
sortie Schengen d'ailleurs au Conseil
des ministres intérieurs je répète sans
cesse que nous reposons la question de
pourquoi la Commission reporte sans
cesse la date d'entrée et cette entrée
sortie Schengen est extrêmement
importante parce que pour comprendre en
quelques instants de quoi il s'agit tout
étranger et même tout citoyen d'ailleurs
d'espace Schengen va avoir une fiche
créée de sa présence sur le territoire
européen et nous pourrons suivre les
entrées les sorties éviter les doublons
de demande de titre de séjour voir que
comment on pourrait suivre cela et tiens
c'est très important parce que c'est
l'interopérabilité entre les fichiers
notamment de toutes les polices
européennes de voir d'où vient cet
étranger par où il est rentré par où il
la sortie par où il est revenu et nous
permet de lutter contre notamment les
risques terroristes puisque ça a été
lancé je le rappelle sous le quinquennat
précédent le précédent simplement si la
France est le seul à mettre le système
en trésorerie Schengen ça sert pas à
grand chose ça va rallonger les délais à
nos frontières et singulièrement dans
les aéroports et dans les ports sans que
aucun pays européen ne nous accompagne
donc nous disons nous que nous on mettra
en place l'entrée Schengen lorsque tout
le monde sera prêt le plus rapidement et
le mieux nous aurions déjà dû le mettre
en place voilà et donc nous sommes tout
à fait d'accord en tout cas je peux vous
assurer pour suivre ce dossier depuis
deux ans visser à l'intérieur que ce
n'est pas la France qui a soit un manque
de développement informatique soit une
volonté de ne pas le mettre en place
simplement nous n'avons pas le même
train de tous les pays de l'Union
européenne et l'ouverture de l'espace
Schengen récent qui sera confirmé
j'imagine par les chefs d'État
n'améliore pas les choses et la sortie
de nos amis britanniques de l'espace
Schengen alors qu'ils étaient
un des pays qui le souhaitaient quand
ils étaient membres de l'espace Schengen
va poser un certain nombre de
difficultés fortes notamment pour le
port de Douvres et pour notamment non
mais dans l'espace européen pardon en
fait des citoyens de pays tiers et donc
créer sans doute un certain nombre de
difficultés pour eux dire mon homologue
britannique me demandant sans cesse
qu'on puisse reporter évidemment ce cet
entrée ce sont quoi nous sommes pas
favorables dans un premier temps en tout
cas au niveau du ministère de
l'Intérieur
sur l'examen des valeurs de la
République nous sommes d'accord je le
dis aussi au président buffet nous avons
d'ailleurs des dispositions législatives
sur ce point mais on est prêt évidemment
amélioré en complément de l'examen de
l'angle sur le refus d'asile vaut qtf il
s'agit bien de deux actes administratifs
différents dans l'occasion d'en reparler
avec le Conseil d'État mais je pense que
c'est pas un allongeant les débats ici
qu'on y arrivera il y a bien sûr un
recours je lisant le garde des sceaux il
y a un recours contre l'acte uqf qui
restera notre volonté c'est qu'il soit
extrêmement lié et extrêmement réduit ce
recours en temps mais qu'il existe
évidemment contre l'acte administratif
qui sera qui sera pris pour Monsieur
pour Monsieur Lecomte alors en fait
monsieur le compte vous avez fait c'est
formidable parce que vous avez fait une
une chronique ou peut-être même un
plaidoirie contre votre propre bilan
parce que vous dites il y a pas assez
d'argent dans les préfectures bah oui
vous êtes tout à fait raison monsieur le
compte 11000 agents que vous avez
supprimé en 5 ans c'est vous qui les
avez supprimés 11000 la Cour des comptes
tout le monde le dit nous sommes le
premier gouvernement non non depuis que
je suis ministre en effet sous
l'autorité sous l'autorité de voir film
de Jean castexte de La Première ministre
quand j'étais misé au public on a arrêté
la suppression de pose la préfecture et
depuis que je suis mise à l'intérieur
depuis Jean Castex et Elisabeth borne on
augmente vous n'avez pas suivi dans
votre programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur en tout cas vous l'avez voté
en première lecture donc j'en étais fort
heureux on augmente le nombre d'agents
dans les préfectures vous vous avez
supprimé 11000 postes 11000
postes je vous ai écouté voilà avec
attention 11000 postes vous avez
supprimé après vous nous dites comme le
coq de Chanteclerc en pensant que vous
faites lever le soleil vous dit bah
alors c'est terrible ça les gens sont
mal reçu en préfecture bah oui parce
qu'il y a moins de personnes et
effectivement si vous n'avez pas
supprimer tous ces postes lorsque vous
étiez en responsabilité on aurait été on
aurait été bien au courant deuxième les
contrôles aux frontières c'est
formidable les contreforts c'est
contraire au droit européen et ce serait
vraiment ce qu'on a le qui a mis en
place ces contrôles frontières appelé le
mois en 2015 je me rappelais plus très
bien ok voilà vous l'avez demandé vous
avez demandé monsieur monsieur le
sénateur vous avez demandé trois fois
sur votre gouvernement et nous sommes
huit pays mais permettez-moi de vous
répondre permettez-moi de vous répondre
c'est des vérités que vous n'écoutez pas
vous aurez rencontrer plus souvent
Bernard Cazeneuve parce que
manifestement vous êtes bien éloigné de
la politique qui défendait lorsque il
était en responsabilité au ministère de
l'Intérieur et je ne cite même pas
Manuel Valls parce que pour vous
j'imagine que ça ça devient quelque
chose de horticaire mais en tout cas les
2000 à l'intérieur que vous avez eu
défendent exactement ce que nous
défendons et vous devrez vous aurez
jouir sur les contrôles en frontières il
y a 8 pays je rappelle d'ailleurs que la
5 sociaux-démocrates de vos camarades
qui ont mis des contrôles aux frontières
effectivement l'Union européenne
pourquoi n'ont pas pour des questions
migratoires pour des questions de lutte
contre le terrorisme et si nous avons
rétabli les contrôles aux frontières
encore très récemment c'est justement
sur le cas de la teinte aux trois
chrétiens de la basilique de Nice et
c'est évidemment personne à ce moment-là
et c'est pas en ce jour d'attentat que
vous pouvez dire le contraire ne
pourrait retrouver une autre chose que
celle de la maîtrise de nos frontières
sur les visa Baladur mais vous avez été
en responsabilité combien de temps
combien de temps vous êtes mais moi je
suis pas contre la suppression des
Isabelle adure c'est tout est différent
entre nous vous commencer vous pensez
vous pensez monsieur le sénateur que
désormais il faut pouvoir permettre à
tous les étrangers qui sont sur l'île de
Mayotte de venir sur le sol réunionnais
sur le sol métropolitain ça se voit vous
êtes pas allé être extrêmement souvent à
Mayotte et que vous l'avez pas dire à
vos camarades et lui ici Maoré c'est une
situation absolument incroyable qui se
passe à Mayotte chacun est convaincu et
les visa va dur porte leur nom il date
du premier ministre Baladur ça ne
rajeunira personne j'étais même pas en
sixième monsieur le sénateur vous
faisiez je crois déjà en partie de la
politique sur l'asile vous dites il y a
deux types d'asile différents mais mais
il y a deux types de sujets il réside à
côté et il y a l'immigration de l'autre
et qu'en 70% des demandes d'asile sont
négatives après la CNDA 70% après la
CNDA c'est bien qu'un petit problème
d'orientation quand même monsieur le
Center chacun sait il faut vraiment
avoir les yeux fermés ou extrêmement
naïf on va voir qu'il y a d'une part des
gens qui méritent absolument l'asile
bien évidemment et d'autre part de
personnes qui utilisent l'asile pour
rester illégalement sur le de la
République mais chacun le sait
rencontrer les agents de l'OFPRA il vous
le diront tous les jours sans aucune
idéologie et notre travail justement est
embêté du fait que les personnes qui
doivent avoir l'asile mais beaucoup de
trop de temps à la voir et donc vivre
dans une ancienne de paupérisation
extrêmement importante parce que tous
ceux qui ne doivent pas avoir l'asile
l'utilisent comme une voix d'immigration
illégale c'est la vérité première et
d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens l'ont dit et
c'était mon vrai que je vous renvoie au
débat parlementaire que portait
également le manuelage ces dernières
Cazeneuve d'ailleurs je veux dire à
chacun ici quand vous citez qu'il y a eu
30 textes depuis 1982 je vous rappelle
que vous faites tous ce procès de votre
votre propre passé nous avons présenté
un seul texte en un quinquennat donc
quand il y a eu 30 textes en 40 ans je
comprends la difficulté ça s'explique
d'ailleurs il fait dans la de la
jurisprudence qui est complexe des
engagements internationaux de la France
qu'il faut rétablir ou des phénomènes
migratoires qui naissent du fait de la
déstabilisation des pays mais c'est pas
en soi un argument qui est un texte en
40 ans puisque nous avons un seul en six
ans donc avouer que ce n'est pas un vrai
un vrai argument troisième sujet vous
parliez des irréguliers que nous ne
n'avons pas comme d'accepte ton trou et
que nous avons pas régularisé j'aurais
dû juste vous donner à chiffrer
également monsieur le sénateur en 2012
lorsque Monsieur Hollande est arrivé au
responsabilités 208 000 irréguliers sur
le territoire national inscrit à l'AME
on pourrait tout à fait penser on sait
pas combien d'irréguliers en France par
nature on peut penser que l'ame c'est
quand même la chose la moins contestable
puisqu'il faut être irrégulier et on
peut penser que quand même beaucoup
d'irréguliers s'inscrivent à la me
puisque c'est effectivement nécessaire
pour soigner ces étrangers qui peuvent
être malades 315 000 en 2017 donc on a
augmenté de plus de 100 000 irréguliers
inscrits à l'AME soit très
responsabilité c'est vrai qu'il a
augmenté sous le quinquennat du
président Macron de 315000 à 350 000
c'est une augmentation malgré le fait
qu'en 2020 et 2021 nous ne pouvions pas
reconduire des étrangers dans leur pays
du fait du covid il y a pas d'espace
aérien c'était plus compliqué de le
faire
une augmentation elle est certes
importante et elle mérite d'être
régulier monsieur président de la
commission des lois mais enfin il n'a
rien à voir avec l'augmentation
exponentielle que vous avez connu et
vous n'avez pas à l'époque fait le
courage on portait par la Premier
ministre et par ministre du Travail de
proposer des régularisations dans une
loi puisque vous avez mis en place la
circulaire Valls dont je rappelle et ça
a été dit par le ministre du Travail
c'est 30000 régularisations 23000
familiales 7000 au nom du travail donc
de donner pas des leçons de
régularisation et d'humanité quand vous
avez pas été capable de le faire lorsque
vous étiez en responsabilité je crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit un peu plus
constructif et un peu plus objectif
lorsqu'on parlera de ces sujets monsieur
le Sénator si vous le permettez sur la
question de Madame de Monsieur Laurent
sur le juge unique il s'agit pas selon
si je peux me permettre de généraliser
le juge unique à la sendéa il s'agit de
permettre le juge unique à la CNDA c'est
très différent et de laisser à la CNDA
le choix de sa formation soit elle
considère qu'il s'agit de requérant
assez facile soit pour donner l'asile
soit pour le refuser je prends l'exemple
de nationalité pour lequel on a très peu
de taux de protection les ivoir par
exemple il se peut que quelques
ivoiriens et l'asile en France enfin
l'immense majorité de ces Ivoiriens ne
les pas ça pose pas de question de
principe ça peut être un juge unique
s'il s'agit de question complexe
l'orientation sexuelle les réfugiés
d'une manière d'un pays qui serait en
partition je prends du Soudan qui est
une question extrêmement complexe ou des
questions de jurisprudence avant que
l'état des bandes arrive type
jurisprudence Kaboul qui avait pris la
CNDA on laisse évidemment le soin à la
cour de choisir sa formation et de
siéger soit en collégial soit en juge
unique il s'agit pas pour le
gouvernement de proposer la
généralisation du génie qui essaye de
laisser le choix c'est une demande qui
est formulée en partie elle-même par le
Conseil d'État et par rapport car rendu
le président la serre donc on peut avoir
des différences évidemment mais je pense
que sur ce point il s'agissait pas si
vous permettez de vous corriger de la
proposition du gouvernement même si j'ai
bien compris que vous aviez pas eu mais
pas le texte qui n'existe pas encore ben
généralisation du du juge du juge unique
de deux derniers points peut-être à
Monsieur benaroche en mer sur les autres
intervenants on aura un débat je crois
voilà il est à 19 59 vous suivez ce
débat depuis 17h30 en direct sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat nous allons
interrompre ici le suivi de ce débat sur
l'immigration mais ce débat sur
l'immigration reviendra avec le projet
de loi de l'exécutif qui sera présenté
au début de l'année 2023 elle est très
belle suite des programmes sur Public
Sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraires de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres est-ce que nous sommes en
train d'entrer dans une aire de
glaciation des rapports humains sous
l'effet de la révolution numérique qui
incline à l'égoïse à l'égotisme même aux
narcissisme aux communes notarisme enfin
à tous ces mots barbares
bref est-ce que nous sommes en train
d'aller vers la des liaison sociale
est-ce que nous assistons à la fin de la
sociabilité c'est d'ailleurs le titre
que nous avons donné à cette émission
pour en parler avec nous Daniel Cohen
bonsoir Daniel vous publiez homo
numérique US chez Albin Michel vous êtes
un chercheur en économie très connu et
reconnu vous dirigez vous avez l'École
de Paris d'économie ou vous diriger un
laboratoire de la rue d'Ulm le CPM est
là vous avez vous sortez de votre
discipline pour prophétiser la société
dans laquelle nous allons et où le
numérique joue un rôle clé et pas
forcément réjouissant mais avant de
parler cela avec vous nous allons
échanger avec Daniel le tartakowski
bonsoir Daniel et ce soir vous vous
publiez vous diriger en fait avec quatre
de vos collègues historiens une histoire
de la rue de l'Antiquité à nos jours
chez Talandier donc vous êtes
historienne vous avez enseigné à Paris 8
vous avez présidé le Comité d'histoire
de la ville de Paris
et là vous dirigez cette cette histoire
de la rue pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
choisi tout d'abord comme objet la rue
comme objet d'investigation scientifique
alors le sujet je rend César qui est à
César l'idée revient à Joël Cornette et
on a réuni des collègues qui avaient
tous touché à la rue de par leur
recherche scientifique mon Catherine
saliouet une spécialiste de la rue soit
Antioche dans l'Antiquité les quatre
autres à savoir Claude Gauvard Joël
cornette Emmanuel schurex et moi-même
nous avions tous dans nos travaux
abordés sous un angle quelconque la rue
et on s'est réuni on s'est dit essayons
de non pas juste à poser nos travaux
mais de penser la rue sous toutes ses
approches la rue surtout ces angles et
finalement en travaillant c'est moi qui
me suis
occupé de la période contemporaine je
suis contemporainiste il y a un retour
de la rue il y a un retour de la rue qui
ne mettait pas un par de façon aussi
nette avant d'engager le travail on va y
revenir ce qui frappe tout d'abord en
vous lisant c'est que depuis